what's up guys and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
right guys if you haven't liked shared
or subscribed to at least if you've
watched two of our videos over here
and you ain't subscribed then we got
beef
okay beef
my name is pearl as you can see i've had
a uh try i've gone into transition i
have transitioned into a handsome black
man um you guys can see that right yeah
yeah well right okay yeah um you know
respect can you respect my pronouns
today please
respect all my pronouns today please
okay
but yeah thank you all for coming um
the topic today is kevin samuels okay um
he's recently passed as you guys may or
may not know and um yeah we're gonna
we're gonna dig a little bit deeper into
like who he is you know what his legacy
was what he's what he said we didn't say
what you liked we didn't like but before
we do that guys could you all like go
around and let people know
your name
your age
and your relationship status
start there i'm terrence i'm 36 uh and
i'm in a relationship
i'm stephanie i'm 24 and i am single
my name is trading i'm 26 and i'm in a
relationship
hi i'm shimari i'm 21 and i am single
hi i'm abraham i'm 24 and i'm it's a bit
complicated right now
that's still a status at this moment in
time guys like um right so we know kevin
samuels like recently passed um
and there was
on the male side there's a lot of men
that followed him and they were like you
know they were heartbroken you know and
a lot of the a lot of the females that
that i interacted with were actually
quite happy that it was that he actually
died which is i feel like he's kind of a
little bit bad do you know what i mean
but the first question is
what did kevin samuels do wrong
he wants to start what did he do wrong i
don't think he did anything wrong i
think he was
i think he was very controversial in my
opinion i think he said a lot of things
um
factually but to
um trigger emotional response i think he
probably stirred the part a little bit
more than he should have
but with regards to his topics i don't
see anything wrong
for saying what he did in my personal
opinion yeah yeah i think he just spoke
the truth to ellis yeah you know and not
everyone likes hearing the truth and
he's just a bit too honest to say yeah
was the question again like what did he
do wrong because people were celebrating
his death man okay so i have a question
you said that he tells the truth do you
do you agree with everything that he's
said
well certain things you know but i just
believe that you know he just he was
just straight up honest about it it's
things that people are scared to admit
or talk about you know certain things
you might agree with but you can't say
because you're scared of what other
people might believe and he wasn't
scared of that he was just like this is
the truth if you like it you like it if
you don't
you don't like it yeah that's that
um so
i personally think and this is just from
the understanding i have of his content
because i wasn't an avid watcher
um
i think that in my opinion the
conversations he was having about what
serves as a foundation for a
relationship because he he positioned
himself as a dating coach
i think that he focused a lot on the
superficial attributes of what people
look at when they're trying to partner
with with each other so for example he
would speak about you know men in how
they look at a female's physical
attributes you know and some of those
things and how that's going to be the
main attract attraction factor when
you're trying to have a partner and he
would say with women it may be looks but
it's also a man's financial status and
you know all of these things and i feel
like that does play a role in
partnerships but i think that in
comparison to these long-term
relationships where you have people who
build a foundation that stands a test of
time where someone isn't you know
looking their best all the time or they
lose their money i think that that
foundation of superficiality is
something that he focused on and i don't
think that's substantive for a long-term
partnership and if that was his
objective to cultivate long-term
partnerships i think that that's where
he fell short
okay so you've gone gone april well i
mean what you said i'm not saying i
disagree with you but i disagree with
you because what he's saying is for
example
where we originally come from people
kind of see it that way for example
let's say in africa or something like
that right yeah yeah
normally the rich you know like if you
want to marry someone their parents even
the family itself does a guy have money
yes or no if you don't even if they you
know you love the person
yeah you know your demand doesn't have
money it's very rare your family's going
to allow you to be with that man yeah
right and then obviously the other
reverse you know if the man wants to
marry someone of course he knows he has
the money and he's in a good state he
wants beautiful kids he wants you know
go home like a
okay i don't want to say like a prize
you know like oh friends come over like
yeah look at my wife you know she's
beautiful blah blah blah blah you know
reverse you know the wife is doing the
same thing oh look at my husband he's
rich he's got this we live in a big
house of course it's not everybody but
i'm saying majority so i feel like he
just went ahead and just you know just
that's how he saw it and that's how most
of us
in our country is as well even right now
that's the reality over there but of
course here is a bit different but over
there i you know i agree with some of
the things he's was saying because that
was a reality
for example in africa yeah but over here
the reality is very different i think
it's the same thing i think it's exactly
here in america or at least the western
countries it's the same thing if not
worse
you know what women what women what
majority of women go for a certain type
of women women go small and what men go
for
are all this not all the same thing but
not just in africa and i feel like he
saw that and he was just talking about
what what on what the average 20 to 25
year old male or female would go
for in the opposite sex would be the
exact same thing yeah you know
you would want to be paid for on the
first date so if a guy doesn't have the
money therefore he's not you won't even
look at him so i think
i understand what you're saying in terms
of him being superficial but that's just
that's the climate we live in yeah so
he's just speaking on that if that makes
sense yeah i don't think that fully
encompasses
everything she says so we're talking
about
superficiality right yeah everything you
can see yeah
she's more talking about the fact that
he portrays himself as a dating coach
but doesn't go past the point of doesn't
go past the point of um
the physic the superficiality
right
i think he's more so coming in at the
initiation part where of course
everything is going to be yeah physical
but in terms of a long-term relationship
what i believe would be along like a
like due to a long-term relationship
it's consistent action yes
so for instance with the first thing you
start out with in the relationship
you do evolve as people you do change
and i think people don't understand that
right
so that consistent action allows you to
say okay cool i'm going to continue
doing this
yeah so and so forth so do you think
that's what he lacked do you think he
lacked the fact that he was like more
depth yeah he needed more depth yeah but
i i think before we can say that we need
to know if he actually came out to be a
a dating coach
no he was an image no he was an image
consultant
that's what i'm saying so i don't i
personally don't know all the videos i
saw of him was him having one to one
conversation um sort of addressing
people's wants and
desires and and sort of ranking them
yeah absolutely i wouldn't say that's a
dating coach per se but i don't know any
of his other content if he's saying he
is a dating coach
or anything beyond um
beyond what he was saying if he's
advising people on how to sustain a
long-term relationship i didn't see that
aspect of him for me to say so so in
terms of i'm going off
um her statement if he's coming off as a
dane coach if he's an image consultant
yeah that's different yeah that's that's
a little bit different but even then
i don't think he did anything wrong by
stating
he gave statistical facts if we're going
to be completely honest the way he
delivered it right
at people in terms of do you do you
think women don't like facts
no i don't i just don't feel like they
can
handle it within themselves if they if
they would if the shoe was to fit right
like if the shoe fit i don't think they
would be able to say to themselves i am
what exactly what he's describing yeah
and they don't want to look in the
mirror and say
he's talking about it i wouldn't say
that's the case for everyone i want to
say that's the case for everyone but in
terms of it's as i said delivery
because the people that was the people
that were celebrating is deaf yeah
men weren't celebrating his death like
that yeah like go sorry i i think also
uh another aside from
the dating advice he had um some very
different beliefs and
um say
this when he was talking with the lady
and i think she had gotten a divorce or
something but basically he was saying if
your child is saying that
your partner sexually assaulted them
that you shouldn't believe the child
um no no this is on video like he said
that you shouldn't why would you believe
the child like uh they're lying like
you're gonna hang on no i'm not no no
i'm not making this up he's like he's
like you know you're gonna give away
your relationship for your child like
you're just gonna believe your child and
ladies like hell yeah if you're you're
telling me that a grown adult is
touching my child why would i and he
said that i don't i don't i haven't seen
that you get to touch it i need to see
that i need to see that i need to be
able to
i'm not saying you're lying but no he
did i don't know
my feelings are not in this like this is
quite literally like the one of the most
controversial things before his passing
like quite recently and he's like why
would you believe the child and so that
that is very
no if he said that that's wild yeah yeah
he said that it was something to do with
if your child comes out the bath naked
and and
your significant other was to look at
them
that's that's what i remembered like and
then the the case was if the child said
something
but i can't remember
like if that's the case then yeah that's
a bit yeah that's wild if he said you
know believe that i just don't i just
heard the the part where
of course like you come out that place
naked it's your child like it's a child
like what because
there's two parts to it it's like okay
it's a child so technically if they come
out naked i know it's a bit weird like
you shouldn't see them that way anyway
yeah
okay
they run around that way anyway yeah
yeah children do they don't do that yeah
um so
but on the other hand it's like okay
this person is not my child's father so
that may be a different angle towards
right so
if they come out the shower naked and
then they're looking at them and then
they say something yeah that's a
different story because that's not your
child's father what else did he do wrong
do you think
i don't think he did i think
if he did do anything
it's a bit in the middle because i do
believe that some of his advice
was head on you know like
if
meeting someone you're going off of
looks just meeting someone doesn't mean
that that's going to be the substance of
your relationship but firsthand oh how
does this person look
like you're not walking up to someone
that is unattractive in your eyes
um
and so you know
no
like sure lose weight you know you want
to be in your best health um
changing no women didn't like him saying
that no but that's that's they don't
like him saying yeah i know that but the
thing the fact of the matter is a lot of
people
don't do not find like
fat attractive listen i know plenty of
guys that like big girls
no no i'm not saying that but i like a
little bit of a footballer in myself you
know what i'm saying
like
you got a little bit more food
skinniest person but you know as long as
you're maintaining health and i think
that was his point of saying
you know
do something with yourself you can't be
in your worst condition and wondering oh
why the next person doesn't like me [ __ ]
you don't even like yourself so how will
someone else like
um so i think it was more on that side
but i uh
what do you think of it is delivery the
delivery was terrible yeah this is what
i described kevin sanders that's right
i described kevin samuels here yeah as
the amazon delivery driver yeah he just
throws your package at the door
yeah he froze your packet at the door
however the package stood inside yeah
that's true the thing that you need the
thing that you want is still inside and
you got upset and angry at the way it
was delivered you not every amazon
delivery driver is going to knock on
your door and be like how you doing man
how you doing sir here's your package
have a good day some of them are going
to throw it at you don't just go and go
in the next but the question for me is
did you get your package yeah but was
the package broken when i got it no it's
it's intact
how do you know
it's intact because hypothetically yeah
it
happens
like yeah
you didn't say that hypothetically you
said he's the amazon driver that threw
the food the package yeah yeah
but the package they open up the package
whether it's broken if it's broken
that's because that's the difference
yeah right exactly okay okay the message
is what's inside yeah
okay okay so you can get the message
someone can give you a message they can
tell you like um
your trainers are black
and they can say your trainers are
[ __ ] black
it's the same message yeah right but it
was delivered differently yeah okay and
here's what i want to say to that
because i think i saw something about
this online because i saw a lot of
conversations about you know kevin
samson's legacy and one thing i saw that
i think is critical is talking about
like impact versus intent
so
you know let's say that kevin samuels
really wanted to position himself as
someone who's providing this counsel to
people so they can make decisions based
on what's available to them fine that
could have been his intent right but
then the impact when you are essentially
be rating because some of the videos i
saw he was downright be rating these
people like there's no way to get around
it um i saw videos of him berating both
men and women and so let's say that he
wanted to provide this advice to them um
so that they could basically you know
improve their lives and you know make
better decisions
the way he went about it was almost like
an insulting way and i feel as though
like that kind of like the impact of
that is hurtful so whether or not the
message was even received is
questionable because now they're so
focused on their hurt and the things
that have been done to them that they're
not able to see okay is there any truth
in what he's saying and i think that's
right
i think it is i think kevin samuels is
older okay yeah and the two people that
tell the truth unequivocally in my in my
experience i are children and old people
a child will look at me like oh you've
got a bogey in your nose that's what a
child would do right because they don't
then it's the innocent and then the
older person's like what's that [ __ ] in
your nose
and the thing is i think with kevin
samuels
he's an older person who just wanted to
say what he wanted to say he didn't care
about your feelings he just wanted to
say what he wanted to say i think i
think his delivery was necessary even if
it was a bit harsh it was necessary
because
from the videos i saw he's talking to
he's talking to people who are deluded
so
again from the things from the videos i
saw not everyone who he spoke with so
for example if
if i'm sitting here and telling you i
want to get rihanna
yeah
that's my goal and that's why i
deserve nothing less
in reality you guys are gonna be
thinking what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
reality and if you wanted to be honest
with me you would speak to me the way
kevin samuel spoke depending on how i
how um
braggadocious i was in saying i deserve
rihanna and nothing else okay so the the
women and men i saw him speak to were
people who seemed entitled and for
people like that you can't be
nice or soft you have to kind of be
direct and harsh with them because it's
a reality check do you know what i think
it is also women are used to in my
experience women are used to other women
talking to them and lying to them
in my experience like women will no your
hair looks amazing girl don't worry
about knowing that your hair doesn't
look amazing right and when women are
going to a man for advice
and they want it honestly he's going to
give honesty and women in my in my
experience can't take honesty they say
they want it but they actually can't
take it because if you're brutally
honest with a woman it cuts deep to her
soul do you know what i mean like guys
speak to guys a certain way and guys
know that they can speak to guys and say
and guy can have a dry kneecap yeah
right and he'll be like yo bro your
kneecap's dry brother but if a girl did
that to another girl she's like oh my
gosh she's hating oh my god why she say
it like that like so women take things
differently from men and i think that
has to be really like put into
perspective when
thinking about his message because kevin
samuels was a man and women were coming
to a man for advice
and he told the advice like a man would
tell a man yeah also
i think after the first few
10 50 videos everyone going to him knows
what they're going for
you know where you're going this is
and you're not saying anything different
you're not sort of doing research and
preparing yourself to sort of catch them
out you're going to say the exact same
thing the last 50 women or men said
knowing what he's going to say to you so
yeah i had one problem i had one problem
when i watched his videos at certain
points is that he hates when people over
talk him yeah he does but he overtalks
people yeah
he does he no
yes which is fair i don't know it's his
show
advice though no but i don't like
hypocrites yeah true that's true i don't
feel that i don't know i don't like no
it's not fair to be a hypocrite it's
fair to be here
hang on a minute i'm i'm pearl right now
okay and this is my show and if people
are confused yeah i am pearl
you if you guys chew the paper here i am
but if if if this is my show yeah
and i'm like the moderator of the show
yeah and i'm trying to have a show and
i'm trying to moderate it and i'm trying
to get somewhere and you're trying to
talk over me i will tell you don't do
cover me because i've actually got
something to do yeah i've got i've got a
vision
yeah yeah so i don't i don't think
that's wrong no that's not wrong
that's what i said he also would speak
over people so when somebody's making
the point he'd speak over them so that's
why he mentioned now you start talking
right now you start talking right right
so if i start talking over you as you
started speaking exactly
listen this is a dictatorship this is
not a democracy now
but the thing is even if sir even if you
were to overtalk me
i'd let you talk
and then but i wouldn't say my point i'd
be i'd be stuck on i'd be i'll tell you
that you overspoke me and i tell you
that you're a hypocrite and then what
then then everyone everyone that's
watching that's fair will know that
you're a hypocrite that's fair if that
if that's your tactic it's not a tactic
it's not a tactic but it's just like
it's it's just like
why why
it's about respect do you go to the
doctors hold on it's about respect
yeah
if someone if someone if you say okay
cool i'm going to give you the respect i
i deserve the respect of not being
overspoken by
then you should also
treat someone as you'd like to be
treated yeah
cool but you go to the doctors
yeah sometimes sometimes and when you go
you're going you need for something
prominent right yeah when i need that
and when they're talking you cut them
and try you know finish their sentences
okay no
but they can stop you right or not yeah
exactly because you're going to them
they know what you came yeah but you
have to tell them what's wrong first
exactly
so they're they're not going to cut you
off without you saying your case and
point whatever you're coming there from
because they need the full information
in fact more time than not i feel like
doctors ask more questions than even
what you're giving them in the first
year in the first time
i feel like it's a power trip whether
it's your show or not but there's no way
to finish it
yeah yeah it's your show but why do you
have to talk over other people and why
does yeah you're way of the highway but
if that was the case nobody would come
on your show because if nobody liked
that nobody would show up
but then have you ever spoken to it like
you were saying before have you ever
spoken to like a deluded person and just
being frustrated what they're actually
saying yeah and i think a lot of the
time that's what was happening with
kevin samuels he was speaking to people
thinking i've done this a million times
and what you're saying to me is absolute
bs
yeah i'm not going to sugarcoat it yeah
i'm just going to tell you what it is
and i think that's a lot of what it was
so when people are saying he done that
he shouldn't have spoken to people like
that i just think that he had done this
a million times
but at the same time you see that on
your show that's your show so either way
either way so the people going there you
know what you're going to get him
inviting people on the live you know
what you're going to get so you can be
frustrated but that's your show
you're making money off this so you're
making an image you're building a brand
off there so you can't be frustrated
that but i mean
it's like what he was saying yeah but
he's trying to help these guys but
they're trying to cut him off taking a
note he like i said he's done it a
million times but i think he's saying
two plus two and then he knows the
answer you tell you no it's full what if
the doctor told you what if the doctor
told you you had a cold right now
yeah i feel like he's right because i
sound like i got cold so
what if doctor told you i covered right
now obviously
right yeah
let me leave
[Music]
he told you right now the way you look
you look like you have cancer i'll tell
you explain to me because he's the
professor he's explaining it to you
right now you look you look like you
have cancer oh and then we'll go
investigate okay what do i need to do
next why was it is my eyes is it my lips
is it my nose what what is it and then
and then and then consistently he's
giving you all these different advices
and he's consistently telling you you
have cancer you have cancer you're going
to believe you're cancer i mean he's the
expert bro you know i mean like i don't
know if i don't i think in this
hypothetical you don't have anything
right
one at a time one at a time what's that
good to have coming right now yeah i
know the doctor announced you're riding
right away yeah yeah you might have to
kill that one i think what you're
missing is i i understand him cutting
people off
if he deems whatever they're saying yeah
to be irrelevant but the point is if you
don't like being caught off don't cut
people off you won't have a conversation
if you both keep cutting each other off
i think that's what um
you go ahead just go cut him off
i think i think the difference is if
you're if your
argument is that he would have been
tired of hearing the same thing
if i'm tired of doing something like you
know you're sick of going stop doing it
stop doing it if i know that i'm just
gonna like receive the same feedback
same
if i'm gonna keep getting this and i'm
sick of hearing it why would i keep
doing it yeah sorry but then there
wasn't wasn't there just an element of
it being a shonen
wasn't there an element of this being
like this is a show now yeah and that's
what i was gonna ask because you
mentioned that um kevin samuels was
trying to help people do you really
think that was his objective or do you
think that now he's just trying to
provide some entertainment value so i
think it really just like you know
you're trying to run a show you know
if i know that i'm good
there's a video i'm saying feedback
there's a video of him saying
how you know you can go viral and the
things that you can do because it's easy
it's easy people are going to go like
off of sound bites for one but it's easy
it's easy uh
today to say something
and if someone doesn't like it like bad
press is probably
even better than than good press these
days because what what it is is instead
of oh oh did you see like oh i like this
new outfit no
you hate it ah do you see that [ __ ] she
has on that's ugly oh yeah you see that
[ __ ] and now everyone is saying the bad
stuff that's going around so it's
circulating his
but that was like kind of a plan for him
so you just think it went from did you
think that it started out as like i'm
gonna help people and then morphed into
now i've got a shelter right i generally
i generally don't believe he was trying
to help anybody i think that he was his
intention
was to put people in their place that's
why to put ignorant people in their
place because
that would be helping them okay yeah to
a degree but the you know the desire is
not it's not waking up saying i want i
really want to help these people it's
like i really want to talk some sense
into them and put them in their place
and you're saying to check them in a
rude way versus help them yeah because
help it would be a completely different
delivery yep you know completely
different really 100 absolutely
absolutely i don't think he had to be as
rude as he was
sometimes it was a little bit too rude
but if you imagine you're talking think
of you're talking to a to a brat
you and you you can see this brett is
going to grow up to be whatever right
you're not trying to help you want to
put them in their place you're going to
be like where's where's their parents
whatever it is they do if a child is on
the floor kicking and screaming and
throwing things your desire is not to
yeah you want to help the the brat but
your desire is to
is to
do you want to hear but he wasn't but if
you're talking to adults yeah right yeah
so there would be women that would phone
into kevin samuel's show
and they would
be a woman that had three children for
three different
baby fathers right and then be saying
this
she'd want a guy like i don't know
tyrese or something do you know what i
mean it's like
he's not trying to help that woman he's
trying to he's trying to check her to be
like your your expectations are
unrealistic i'm not even just but they
but women did not like hearing that
their expectations are unrealistic
what you were saying when you said oh
women don't really like hearing the
truth like bang
like they know it
but they don't want you to say it
so who's going to tell them i think
that's a huge thing
i'm going to tell you the truth yeah and
that's what people didn't like and at
the end of the day remember you can't
please all help you know do everything
in everybody's way you know i want to be
talked in a certain ways she wants to be
talked inside and waiting everybody has
their own way and he just said listen
i'm just going to say the truth yeah and
you know that's the way i saw it and
he's like listen whether you like me
hate me you came to me for
the truth i'm going to tell you the
truth
mm-hmm i just feel like people have a
hive mentality
like like they don't really have their
own opinion
and even if your opinion aligns with one
or the other you haven't really thought
about you can't if someone wants to ask
you to explain yourself you wouldn't be
able to i don't i don't like that i
don't like if someone says okay
i don't like this okay why
um
just because just just because like and
then they might recite something they've
heard before
from someone else from someone else
who's heard it from someone else exactly
so it's it's like there's a hive
mentality so in terms of women that
might be a
like like kevin simon would say i'm
gonna quote him like this bad b
mentality or this boss mentality where
um they might be taking a stand against
men but there's only certain women that
do that and they do that for a specific
reason but then of a woman try just
because they're women they will adopt
that mentality as well just because they
have no reason to they haven't
accomplished anything
but just because they're a woman they
they will so do you believe that what
you're just saying that a lot of people
that called into his show were entitled
then they were just entitled yeah
and the males because i've seen them
talk to you yeah yeah yeah the men too
everyone's 100 entitlement 100 that's
what i believe so is that like a deeper
like is that like the the deeper
um conversation
that kevin samuels exposed the entire
generation could get to deeper
conversations if i'm going to be because
i think he exposed
a generation of women who were entitled
that's what i personally think
i don't like women who have gone through
their life making mistake after mistake
after mistake
and then asking
prince charming to come out of the sky
and save them from all the mistakes that
they made yeah
i think that doesn't that doesn't make
any sense because it's like you've made
all of those mistakes in your life you
no one is obligated to save you from all
those mistakes that you made yeah yeah
i think
this is this is this might sound very
off topic but i think memes are the best
things that's ever happened to the
internet and people in general because i
think so what happens is it takes your
depression it takes your sadness takes
your happiness it takes your your old
trauma from back and back in the day and
it puts it into like a little picture or
a video and then everyone can say oh
yeah
i went through that
that means that everyone knows that
they're not alone
the same goes for and it can have the
opposite effect yeah so i'm going so i'm
gonna i'm gonna put it back to what
we're talking about right now in terms
of the fact that
not only memes but you could call it
propaganda but it's really not um
is that
everyone can now say
oh i felt this way
and they feel connect they feel good
enough to say okay i want to put my
opinion out there as well
i want i want to show i want to tell
people how i feel and what i feel like i
deserve sometimes it doesn't even come
from an entire place i feel like they
they're trying to
quote-unquote play into that atmosphere
um but and so a woman calls into the
show
and she's got
three different baby fathers three
different children
and she says as i'm also women now okay
and she calls into your show she's got
three different baby fathers three
different children and she says you know
who i want
i want a man just like jay-z
what what advice would you give those
women
are you even in like his class like
i i i don't think it would be as much of
a problem
say if you're in the same class but if
you're some next day person like if
working class there's no way that you're
going to be with someone like obviously
it's possible but it's just not
realistic like who who wants to be with
you
but no it's not it's not that i don't i
don't think that people have a problem
being with uh
a person with with children so to speak
um but
the difference is the class so jay-z is
not in your class if if you're living
wherever you are you're you're damn sure
not living where jay-z's at yeah but
women are hypergamers though aren't they
so
women tend to try and date up
right so
but this is a thing there's dating up
and then there's trying to date into the
next stratosphere do you know what i'm
saying i'm saying i think it's fine if
you're dating up with someone that is
not too far off from you or is even
comfortable with being with someone on
your level but i don't think if you're
saying a person like jay-z he's not
looking for obviously he's with beyonce
but he's not looking not even her
specifically i i don't think he would
want to be with someone that's even
single with no kids working class
because that's they're not in the same
bracket
they're not in the same bracket no men
yeah
will happily date a woman on the
checkout
yeah
if she displays the right qualities i
agree
as a
she could be she could make 20 grand a
year
if she displays the right qualities
i'll take that yeah am i lying man
i agree women aren't like that though no
men are like that so what advice would
you give to a woman
that comes if it was your show yeah um i
would say most of what she said is just
basically you're not in the same
stratosphere so you need to readjust
your expectations based on what is
available to you um you have three kids
already so you have to understand that
that's already gonna eliminate a lot of
options there are a lot of people who
don't want one kid let alone three
so now you have to look at that that
limits your option then you have to
consider that you're in a different
class you're not to be running into
people like jay-z so obviously you have
to readjust but i think that you know
saying that in this way i think she
would get the message she'd understand
like you know okay i can't really have
that expectation i wouldn't have to
berate her to get the message across
what he would do he would say okay how
much do you make a year yeah what's your
age yeah what's your relationship status
why is it that your relationships broke
down he was very methodical
i think you can do it without belittling
someone no you have to be you have to
but you don't have to belittle them like
the reason why i'm saying that i'm not
i'm not i mean i don't think it should
be little berate people but the reason
why i say it's necessary is because it's
not just the individual's desire to have
jay-z is the individual's desire to have
jay-z whilst looking down on anybody who
was not jay-z so the regular man
what can he prove you know what i'm
trying to say because of that mentality
you have to be belittled no you don't
have to but
it's a reality check yeah it comes with
the delivery of the message because
speaking of the mind because it's one
thing if you just i just want jay-z
that's you know because you know it's
your one it's your goal it's your desire
whatever it is yes but then you're
looking down on other people who haven't
achieved what jay-z's achieved you know
like there are some women who say they
wouldn't date a guy working a nine to
five wow you know so
those and he's got to be above six foot
yeah my my thing is is you have to be
able to match and it's not it's not in
the sense of oh if you give me ten
thousand dollars i have to give you ten
thousand dollars but you have to be able
to match them in some way shape or form
so you can't be saying oh like that that
is the most ridiculous thing because
most people are working class so how you
yourself as a working class person
saying oh no you can't people are
average
yeah you can't have a job but when he
said you're average at best people got
upset yeah yeah true did you see what
i'm saying like it's that truth serum
yeah it's like most people are average
when kevin samuel said now you're
average at best
most the women oh you can't say that
but he was being he was telling the
truth yeah but i saw the video wasn't he
saying on a look scale she's average i
think that's what he was well the thing
is when it comes to men yeah
men
this is for the men in here
we we we have we have we have a look
scale we do and the thing is a lot of
women don't like to acknowledge it
because they think no because you know
what i i feel beautiful i think all
right cool but we're looking at you
we're looking at it
no i think the difference is uh women in
general
we see potential in things and that
that's that's the problem with a lot of
women you don't need to look for the
potential look for the reality because
you can you can be something all day but
you're not
right it's not
it could be but it's not the thing is a
job does not hire you based on your
potential generally they look at your
your resume your cv and say okay what
can you do okay you can do that you can
do it you can do it okay cool cool cool
fine and they hire you then while you're
on the job you may show them that you
have potential to be better than what
you actually are however if you're
coming to me with your resume or your cv
i'm going off that and women's cv and
their resume
we're looking at it
but technically technically if you go to
an interview right
and then they look at your resume if if
the resume was all they needed then why
would there be an interview
good point
sorry say that again if you're going if
if if what your employer is looking for
can be found in a resume why would there
be an interview
uh because they have to see they have to
meet you
because everyone's just on paper exactly
so there has to be some form of
potential involved so for instance if me
and
my men
was to go to an interview
you're the interviewer
you see me
you see him
and you got the same on your on your no
no no i'm just smart
[Laughter]
just casual who are you going to choose
just off appearance
because that's what that's what it is
right
do you know what is i you've everyone's
been to interviews here a lot of the
time
if you display the same qualities on
paper that somebody else displays a lot
of time is personality person not
exactly so within the personality
there's a certain level of um
[Music]
uh
i can't remember the word but like
there's a certain margin of error that's
a word there's a certain margin of error
and then they'll say okay cool
based on his personality and how we feel
he fits into the team
i believe that he can do
said thing
that that is potential
the potential i guess the potential to
fit into a team but
i don't know about that
potential i think that's a match
i think that's a match like do you
qualify
yeah guys um we got some super chats to
read out before we continue
um
i charge read them on my phone all right
good indeed let's have a look at the
super chats here
listen this is a good conversation guys
like we're gonna we're gonna get a
little bit deeper you know
we're gonna get a little bit deeper hang
on let's read some super chats one
second
um
okay
right there's only one here on my phone
uh and it is from
zen
tience he said the female who
well you know zantians no he's he's
pearl's favorite oh okay
the female who commented
on how she would advise if it were her
show she said the same thing kevin
samuels did she just sugarcoated it you
cannot improve without pain pain of
self-reflection working out etc is
painful accept it
true i agree
um hang on
let's see we've got another one 100
from zentian my god what is this male
talking about the memes
you persistently
let me just yeah let me just read it out
my god what is it mel talking about the
memes you put you persistently sound
like a female you have utterly mastered
the art of saying a lot without actually
saying anything
men's words should have more weight damn
damn
let's keep going let's keep going is
there more i can't um
i can't see any more come on dyslexia
uh
have you got them over there yeah cool
all right so we've got a super chat from
johnny b
uh kevin had been talking to men with
the same tone for years and one and no
one cared about it
or his tone as such stop lying to women
treat them the same and respect them as
a man
okay sentience uh to the men who are
decrying don't
interrupt and ks not helping are well
spoken for the women they are hallmark
of masculinity is over talking others if
you can't handle that then learn to grow
thick skin and improve
dog mpa
kevin samuels was a gift to the black
man black women hate everything that
directly benefits black men wb
or sorry bw will never understand what
bm go through most bm
have black women i'm sorry yeah black
women have a disgust for black men long
live kevin samuels
lord have mercy oh let's let's piggyback
off that
yeah let's let's let's do that we're not
finished yet oh sorry sorry apologies uh
we got jc
oh
hypocrite bro you softest
wait wait wait let me look you guys
hypocrite bro you softer charmaine
dane who said that uh jc i think he was
talking to
briana middle
uh sentience uh to the women who are
preoccupied with being hurt about ks men
uh understand that mead sorry that
understand that medicine doesn't taste
good regardless of how medicine tastes
it still needs to cure the disease and
that is perpetuated by feminists
sentience to the woman
stop
with the disingenuous argument either
provide context or don't dilute the
message because that's how false
narratives come about also women are
more preoccupied with their feelings
over facts
um
sentience
synthesis is going for it today yeah
yeah like
the man in the middle needs to learn how
to understand what
an
analogy is no wonder women will seek all
about men can't have gifts running
around do better man become a man
and dog mpa kevin samuels was talking
about being a step dad he said that
a single mom will take care of their
children
a single mom will take their children's
side over the step parent and so don't
date single mothers a vindicate step
child will lie on you
that sounds that sounds more realistic
about that i'm not gonna that sounds
more realistic is he alluding to the
conversation about the child the child
and yeah but i still need to see the
video too yeah i still need to see it
yeah but piggybacking off what one of
the is there more is it anymore that's
all all right yeah it's piggybacking off
the back of that um
do black women find it very easy to
disrespect black men
whoa
okay let's get into it go ahead black
women find it easy to disrespect black
men is it is it easier for black women
because remember when kevin samuels died
there were women twerking on the grave
that had this they had a twerking on his
grave type thing right um vivica fox
came out and said his death was karma i
didn't i i didn't agree with that that
that was awesome is it very easy i think
i think the thing with that is that
a lot of people were not happy with how
he was going about his advice and
obviously
how we were saying that he could
potentially have given a softer
approach yeah and not saying that you
can't give the message but you don't
have to be as harsh um and so with that
if you're being disrespectful while
you're alive you can't expect people to
respect you when you're gone if you were
not respecting them but i don't think
anything
one second you were you were very
adamant that they can yeah okay so i
want to hear yeah i want to hear his
take i wanna hear your statement it's
just like from my own experience you
know like my own experience you know
like go to school here like you have the
black girls they'll have their literally
the nerve to come and do something to
you that you know a white girl would not
do
you know and i feel like black girls
respect white guys
more than black guys wow unless you know
you bring in some sort of
masculinity like i said i mean that's
what i see you know but if you're just
there like trying to be nice
funny and blah blah blah don't take it
as a joke man you know but if the white
guy's nice blah blah blah calm then yeah
that guy's oh he's the prince you know
but the black guy is more calming that's
my own experience that's interesting you
know that's a different approach yeah
the black guy is more like you know a
bit more straightforward you know like
blah blah blah blah are you saying that
black women like the pookies and the ray
rays are you trying to say no no they
like the guys at a little bit more
street is that what you want to say oh
no
a young age you know certain from where
i come from south london you know from
young age i mean when they grow up and
they get common sense yeah you know i'm
saying i'm not this might be too late by
then
might be too late by then
you know i'm just saying i think that's
what i think you know from young ages
like from school
from young age from school yeah that's
what it looks like you know all the
little
the gangsters the bad boys you know they
get all the you know most of the the
black girls in school yeah obviously i'm
not saying i feel like
you're mixing it up because the the bad
boys and the gangsters would be black
because what was it the question was
yeah the question was
do black women because piggybacking off
what was said by one of the chats do
black women find it easy to disrespect
black men
yes but that that what you're saying
sounds completely different um correct
me if i'm wrong but it sounds a bit like
you're only saying that
from growing up that black woman are
going for the bad guys and that has like
who they're attracted to has nothing to
do with who they're respecting or
disrespecting because if i if i like him
and i don't like you that's not me being
disrespectful to you that just means i
like him yeah yeah yeah cool let me
answer it yes because i feel like
we are the same it's easier to just
you know say what we need to say
does that make sense who is we so black
man and a woman
you know but then obviously black white
one and a white black woman and you know
white man is a bit different
you know
so that's what i think you know wait
hold on
you're going to say something
yeah i wanted to respond to this point
because i find it really interesting
because um
i feel like black women by and large
generally go after like black men like
most black women i know are only looking
at and for black men whereas with black
men it's not the same story at all like
black men you know especially as they
get up in rank you know they'll be
looking at anyone but a black woman and
so i think that you know the
conversation about black women openly
wanting to disrespect black men i think
that honestly
i will say there is disrespect but at a
certain point we have to also look at
what a black one being put through
across time like we've seen most
especially in music videos some of the
opportunities where black men have the
opportunity to uplift black women black
women are [ __ ] hoes you know they're
they're never used in a light that you
know shows them positively so
i mean after during that and you know
seeing that messaging over time what do
you expect is going to happen do you
think they're just going to sit there
and like smile of course they're gonna
start to respond is it is the disrespect
okay i don't think disrespect either way
is okay but we have to understand where
did that come from and look at it within
this proper context i'm looking at your
face you're like
hey
but i feel like you're looking that way
because you personally like black women
yeah but
a lot of black men go out of their way
to have like this hatred for black women
like ah oh they're ugly like oh what is
your mom babe what is your mom you're
saying this that in the third what is
your mom what does your grandma look
like because you're damned you're not
saying obviously you don't like them but
um well let's get sigma fraud but no i'm
saying sexually
um but then it's like oh my white queen
or blah blah this down the third snow
bunny no but no you're you're looking
i've never heard a black man say my
white queen liquid snow bunny
all of them it doesn't have to be that
exactly you it doesn't have to be
verbatim my white queen but these same
traits
oh black women are rude or i don't like
the attitude latino woman ah i like the
attitude like the aggression is so
attractive what's the difference yeah um
do black do black women sorry go on let
me
i feel like all your points are valid
yes but you're looking like you're
looking at a pocket of society
no
even what you said about about how
black men are treated by black women
that's
i feel like it may have happened to you
but if i compare my experience to your
experience it never happened to me and
are we talking black women are treating
black men disrespectfully over white men
are we talking across the board what are
we talked about trying to say it's like
an outlandish statement to make oh it's
it's too widespread
um
and what you said in regards to um look
at what black women have gone through
at the hands of black men
i'm like in in what sense like okay it
when okay so you're talking about
rappers addressing black women as the b
word right
but that doesn't count for every black
man no but it's not just the rapture
additionally
one thing we have to be mindful of is
when we're talking about black women
black men and black women
we're excluding africa right we're just
talking about black men and black
people continent of black men who
respect black women and vice versa yeah
so
i'm hearing everything you're saying is
valid but i feel like it may be just
like on a case the case i've never been
to america so i can't say that but i
feel like
from what i hear black men say to black
women i feel like it's equal
the disrespect and the
and the respect it's an it's on an equal
scale i've never
i haven't experienced or haven't seen
an outpour of of black men disrespecting
black women and being proud of it
from what i've seen i'm not i'm not
saying
this is factual but i've never i've
never experienced it what i'm saying is
not even my experience because i am a
fair person um
i i'm on the light side of the black
yeah the bathroom yeah yeah so
um me i benefit from colorism and that's
just the truth but i know what other
people go through especially darker
complexions yes um
i if i'm talking to a black guy and it's
like oh
like what's what's more of your
ethnicity like you know your heritage oh
i oh i'm puerto rican oh i see a little
spicy or or this down the third
why why are you more attracted to me
with me just naming
an island versus when you just knew when
you were thinking oh
just black race the right i i would
attribute that down to
music videos it might be no but it's not
it's not music videos it goes deeper
than that but yeah way deeper it's not
it's not music video it's not music
videos but if you look at if you look if
you look at rapping in the 80s and 90s
there weren't no mixed race
racially ambiguous puerto rican women in
the videos
no i i don't think it's because of
colorism as a whole
however guys we're getting a little bit
off topic yeah um we've got a little bit
of talking topic but
going back to kevin samuels
and trying to keep it a little bit where
we are um was his message
just for black people
because he would speak about black women
a lot but was kevin samuels message just
for black people or did it
did it then um i guess extend to the
rest of the western world
i think he spoke to whoever he spoke to
yeah
i think i think he just he spoke to
whoever spoke to him and whoever that
message is for if that if the shoe fits
and you're not black then
i mean you can take it however you want
but specifically he spoke to black men
and black women so i would say he spoke
i would say that's that's who we
targeted that
because so we didn't you don't think he
specifically targeted the black
community
i don't think that he's specifically
targeted by me community i think yeah i
think i think if he if he if he had a
white person on his on his show he'd
speak about why no no the thing is with
kevin samuels he he's a little bit like
myself i think
in the fact that i can speak
general generally about the black
experience
but
if somebody not of the black experience
speaks to me i can also speak to them
yeah but kevin samuels would
tell you know he would say things like
you know the black family yes our ex you
know i mean the black family you know
black baby uh you know the baby mother
culture in the black experiences x so i
think he i think he wanted
the black people specifically within the
western world to become better than what
they are but in my personal opinion i
think his message then extended further
than that because the men
i think the men
that were hearing his message
were hearing it all over the world yeah
like you can you can really relate
because physic like physical like
physicality
isn't just bound to one race
he's an image consultant right
so
if he's speaking to
a black woman or or
just yeah a black woman
of this and then he says okay how how
much do you weigh
how many pounds
rkg and then what's your height if
there's a white woman within that range
he would say the same thing um he would
say the same
yeah i think it goes back to what you're
saying he started you know aiming at the
black people
but then obviously as things grew for
example he might tell me and i'll take
that idea and use it for a white woman
and then just kind of just when i felt
like this kind of grew more than he
expected but he kept his message like
kept it the same like oh you're black or
you're white i'm going to change the way
i'm going to speak it's like
it doesn't matter who you are i'm just
going to say the truth i'm just going to
speak like he just kept his
way if that makes sense so you don't
think he changes do you think he changed
it up depending on who you were speaking
to i think he spoke to everyone the same
in one way i wouldn't say that because
he used statistics which is the only
reason why i wouldn't say
if i feel like if there was a white
person i think there would be a white
person statistic
because he specifically goes on
particular websites
and he says these are this is this is
just this and this yeah so i feel if he
does if he has done his research i don't
know
but of course
we if there was a white person on the
show we know what the white statistic
would be
so
when i used to see people call up to his
show specifically the women they will
talk about marriage being the end goal
right of like
all of the advice that they were trying
to be giving them um
in your opinion and i want everyone's
opinion on this do you think this
generation
both generations are both millennials
and generation x
z and sorry
z generation x generation z um
do you think they're marriage material
no no no
no
god god right
i feel like um
the like of the likes of cardi b
nicki minaj um they're both married no
no of course but i mean it's very easy
for them to be married they're they're
attractive good-looking women
and there are guys who would
who don't mind their behavior but i feel
like their behavior isn't marriage to me
their behavior isn't
why i would class as
marriage material
but they're married because the men
they're married to are are fine with
their behavior but i feel like
what they do and and promote to the rest
of
the world the world
makes that behavior normal
and
i've basically i wouldn't be in a club
and see a woman twerking and all her
girls are surrounding her recording
they're putting on snapchat and i'm like
i want to marry that one
that's not for me that's not marriage
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with the subject yeah there's nothing
wrong with the act or whatever it is but
when i see that i'm not thinking
marriage i'm thinking sex or i'm
thinking
i'm just not thinking marriage
um
and that's why i would say
they're not really marriage material 100
and it's also the speech
um
i would say that i really think it's
it's really a case-by-case basis i mean
a lot of my friends i would say their
marriage material like the way they get
what generation are they
well i'm 24 so what did that place mean
is that yeah gender that's gen z yeah
yeah so i would say that their marriage
material now i think that a lot of
people are pushing marriage to later and
later so maybe they're like okay i'm
going to live my best life till i'm like
27 28 then i'll start trying to later
yeah so i think that um you know people
depending on what their aspirations are
they tailor their life in that way i
think in every generation you have
people who are they don't want to marry
or they're not really considering that
okay i have to be a certain person to
get what i want but i think in this
generation you know you have people who
want to be married and are positioning
themselves so that they can but then is
that marriage material if you are if you
are
pushing marriage back
to okay i'll live my quote-unquote best
life now is that marriage material
because if your marriage material
managed material if you're if you're
gonna
live your best life meaning hot girl
summer's gonna last a couple of summers
right
like it's to last a couple of summers
is is the man that's going to be coming
after that going to be like yeah i want
that one as my wife yeah
that that like because he's known that
you've lived a couple hot girl summers
do you know what i mean and he's going
to be like
i don't know body count may be up but
you know i'm not i don't know if i
really want to marry that one that's if
he knows
god
now we learn about body count over here
no but the thing is and that's the thing
and that's the thing like that scary
place i think a lot of
people right now are in i think they're
like
i would like to but i don't trust it
yeah
i don't necessarily trust what's going
to go on and i think
yeah that's what i'm asking if it's
marriage material i don't think body
count is a you should be worried about
body count i i think body count is a
great area i agree but yeah i uh tell me
why we shouldn't be writing about boris
body count today um because it's like
you're judging someone he said i'm a
host so you could be a hotel
simple and short
not even i feel like i feel like it's
yeah you know what actually yeah
it's true yeah no yeah you're right oh
yeah you're right
it's long because you're clean right
yeah exactly no no but the thing is it's
not about that for me it's like i'm not
gonna judge someone's whole personality
life and values based on how many people
like the fact that if you were even
honest with me from the very beginning i
feel like honestly in general
is a good sign it is so if a woman came
to you and you wouldn't you fell for her
and she said you know what i've slept
with over 150 men
i don't disagree yeah if a woman came to
you and you saw the videos let's say
she's promiscuous and she's oh but
before i fell in love
because he said he said i fell in love
after he said i fell in love okay so
after after yeah and i saw it after yeah
i don't care
yeah so okay so you're me so you meet a
woman
okay so let's see if it really does
matter so you meet a woman you're on a
date you've done been on a couple of
dates right and then you start talking
you haven't you haven't fallen in love
with her yet i haven't fallen off you
haven't fallen in love with you and she
says you know and she says and she's
honest with you she's like you know what
if i've had sex with like a hundred guys
are you going to pursue it
why not
i think body i know i think body count
can be
i think behavior for me can't be
overlooked so if you're saying body
count but she's had threesomes or she's
had a train runner and stuff like that
i can't even even if your body count is
four
and they ran it is a bit peaked but i
feel like you've being no so it doesn't
matter
no i know i know i know i know what
you're trying to say but it's like
you're being
you're stress testing right now so it's
like you're you're stress testing you're
saying like okay if they had a hundred
it
what what what is your your max capacity
of how what you would allow yeah but at
the end of the day it's like
you're thinking realistically you there
no woman there are women who've had 100
dicks
100 but the per but the
you're not going to find many women with
a hundred me
i think it depends like your stress
destiny isn't what do you know a lot of
women that do no i think it depends
number one does the body think
personally i think it does that's number
one number two oh our generation you
know is it
um are they marriage material yeah that
goes two ways you know i think it
depends you know if i'm both of them
ready yes or no and i'm saying where are
you looking now if i go to the
basketball court i know this girl is
dedicated i know that she's you know got
passion i know she's got determination
she's got potential but if i go to the
strip club like you're saying yeah i'll
go stop someone oh man you're looking
nice i want to marry what if he's going
to say and i think i think it's
different i think it depends on both for
the like you know whoever you're with
you know where they are in life right
now you know what stage they're in life
and you know what they're looking for
and if both of you are ready for it but
if you had to make a statement is is
this generation
married marriage material both men and
women i think i think no i honestly i
don't think so like you can feel that
way but the mindset is so off like our
the world that we live in now is tit for
tat oh oh you cheated on me so let me
cheat on you back no if you cheated on
me and i like really feel some type of
way why don't you remove yourself why
don't you leave the relationship like
why do you think oh now we're both gonna
keep so the rest of the relationship
we're just both going to be cheating on
each other the rest of our life
no like
but i think just the mindset is is
different and i think it could
uh
be
that way because
their angle might not be a marriage in
the beginning it could just be like oh
i'm doing this for fun
um and a lot of people are not living
life with intention so if you're not
living intentionally you're going to do
random things because you don't have a
goal yeah so no we're not we're not
marriage material i mean so if we're not
marriage material
and because that was a very honest
answer by the way why are people phoning
up kevin samuels talking about what
marriage why women
is is that another part of the delusion
i think so because some of those people
like
one uh one of the ladies she's like oh
i i need help like
i can't i can't find a great guy i'm an
entrepreneur i'm a businesswoman i make
over six figures and
and
you know i don't know like and i i have
my own businesses but i i don't like
telling people because then they want to
say oh let me let me be a business
partner or xyz and then
she's like she admits that i'm going for
lower men so if you're saying oh i want
to be with someone why are you going
with someone for someone lesser than you
not saying that you can't find someone
lesser than you that's going to be
worthwhile in what sense what is it as
far as like financially financially yeah
so say
you're you're over a hundred thousand
and you're looking you and you're saying
that you have several businesses um
in that sense i would think these
streams are
profitable at this point um and then
you're gonna say you're gonna go with
average joe that's maybe making 40 000
and it's like oh
why don't you look for someone that's
also an entrepreneur like
but
i just think that's just how you're
saying the people are calling the show
are delusional because you're not
actually you're not actually
looking or meaning what you're saying
you just want someone to sugarcoat or
like the next they don't really want
that
they don't really want that they think
it sounds nice no i think they want it
but then they're under qualified it's
like one they want a job that they they
are not qualified for basically it's not
that i won't say they don't want it i
believe these women do want whatever it
is they're saying but they're not
realistic about their limitations but
that's exactly what kevin samuels
pointed out no but i don't think
if you really wanted something you'd
figure out a way to get it and work on
the steps to get there
yeah but there are limitations you know
uh yeah but then you would work on that
along the way so say well you can't work
if i want to buy a limp
that you three kids already removes a
large large portion of portions of men
that are available to you
kind of goes back to your question yeah
you know why did i go to him because i
feel like they knew the truth yeah but
they just wanted someone they just
wanted to hear it but they got they got
upset i think they wanted to prove it
wrong that's it yeah i think they wanted
to prove it wrong i think they wanted to
make a statement yeah yeah exactly about
what what statement just to challenge
him
that somebody wants to challenge you so
so okay so see see we're talking about
black men and black women now so a black
man like kevin samuels will have will be
truthful have the truth and what you're
basically saying is black men were like
i'mma prove him wrong so i'm gonna go on
his show and i'm gonna try and show him
up
do black women respect black men because
if the black man's speaking the truth
then he's speaking the truth why you
want to go in there and try and stop him
from doing it but i would i'd have to
say the majority of the people who call
are just ignorant so they can't
represent black women yeah if that makes
sense yeah
they're they're ignorant and
caller after call after call out to
caller yeah
if because if
for example there are videos on the
internet of then why do so many women
get angry if they don't represent black
women why were so many women getting
angry for those black women because
those ignorant black people are cover a
large
portion of
the black society
in my opinion i wouldn't say all black
women think like that question right i
wouldn't say all of them think of that
yeah question would you go on kevin
samuels
on live would you go on his little
podcast i would go in there yeah
definitely would you would you ask for
advice or would you just want to have
just a normal conversation i just i just
wanna i'm gonna talk to people who've
got like different minds and different
like mindsets that's that's why i would
go on it i think the thing is when i see
i've i've only seen one video i think i
think everyone's seen it with the
he's done like with a guy
and then he asks like very like if he's
got a big dick or something
you know if you got a big dick
that was hilarious but imagine if he's
asking you the same questions would you
feel comfortable
if he's asking my dick yeah i would say
yeah my dick's fine yeah but it depends
on why he's gone on the show and no but
that's what i'm saying but no i'm just
saying i'm putting them in that in the
game and that's the same guys yeah no no
i'm like i've already said you'd have to
be ignorant to be in that guy's position
that's true did you go and check that's
what was that because that guy was like
making like twenty thousand a year old
like eight hundred a month for some
crazy things like that but you have
someone else
so it's hard to it's hard to address
because a lot of people go on the show
just ignorant yeah they deluded to it
that's why i said if i'm sitting here
saying yeah i deserve rihanna and
nothing else like and all every girl
who's not rihanna's either ugly or broke
or lazy it's like i'm an idiot if i'm
saying some [ __ ] yeah
right and that's what that's that proves
again it proves the point like if if if
people were to put themselves in the
position of the person that's calling
instead of thinking about how they feel
about about what's happening what's
happening exactly then they'll be like
wait hold on why would i go on the show
and knowing that i'm gonna get real yeah
but you know you said something along
the lines of the fact that um you know
black women just were getting mad
essentially for the people who went on
the show
and you know had the experience that
they had but i think that what's getting
lost in translation i don't think maybe
that black woman would have been as
angry if kevin samuels had delivered
because we keep talking about what he
was saying and we can all agree that
maybe there was some truth in it but the
way he was saying it to those women like
i watched some of them like they came up
on twitter i'm like what's going on here
like why is she getting berated like
this and i think people were getting
angry because of that i i didn't see
people really even addressing the mess
and i feel like they were mad because of
what was said
okay i'm gonna use the video as an
example there's a video of two or three
girls who came out of a nightclub
and they were complaining that the men
in there weren't wearing rolexes or
pateks or whatever it is and they were
when for what for what it looks like um
pretty little pretty little things like
10 pounds so
anyone in this room yes if you saw kevin
samuels talking to them like that if you
know that's their mentality there is
nothing wrong with it because you're
deluded how
you're
we're in a nightclub to have fun maybe
meet somebody but not to look at
somebody's wristwatch and say it's not
rolex so if i'm looking at somebody with
that mentality being berated by kevin
samuels i'd feel no type of way because
if nobody speaks to them like that
they're encouraging that behavior and
they're going to go through life with
that mentality and they're going to
spread it to all their friends their
friends are going to spread it to their
friends and to the next generation it's
just going to continue like that so you
have to stop it in its tracks and you
have to make somebody feel little about
the way they think
that's the reason why i'm saying there's
nothing wrong with how he's speaking to
them because
to a woman who's saying that
if she comes across me in a nightclub
and she's like why are you not wearing a
rolex
i can't have a normal conversation
why i'm not wearing it because it has to
which is why i'm saying kevin samuels
saying the things he said in the way
that he says them are necessary okay so
here's my point of contention because i
definitely agree with what you're saying
about like crushing the delusion yeah
what i'm thinking about some of the
videos i've seen where these women were
coming genuinely to seek advice like the
one i'm talking about now though
especially the average at best one i
remember she had come on the the show
and she had said i'm making six figures
i have this business i've tried to date
a spectrum of men just that what's been
available to me but i want to try and
get some more in my league just because
i feel like there's been maybe these men
have been mooching off like she's
telling her he's genuinely trying to ask
for counsel to figure out how do i get a
man who's not gonna feel as though maybe
he's he's not in a position of he
doesn't have to express his masculinity
because i'm making more money than him
or maybe how do i get a man who's more
on my level if you will and he he
berated her he told her that she was
average at best he then said that she
needs to stick to dating men who are
making fifty thousand dollars because
that's all she can qualify for and so
when you're berating someone like that
who actually came seeking counsel is it
really necessary to go that hard you
know why i think
just because i think i think there's a
there's a small percentage of his
content or his
his demographic or audience what he's
doing that is for entertainment not
entertainment that is just i'm just
doing it i'm being simon cowell that's
basically what it is
in my opinion because
it it seems like a like a um
like a script it's he's just following
the script okay but but you also know
why
because as men and as women you guys
also know you ladies or something women
lie they embellish the truth
okay
a woman will tell you
a woman will tell you okay yeah
i was dating this guy
no you weren't you were having sex with
him
dude i'm saying like they would they
would literally tell you to lie because
in their head they want to make it sound
better than what it actually was oh yeah
i was dating this guy and
you were having sex with the guy you
were friends with benefits all right so
why are you now looking and i think a
lot of women
that um called his show
they they mistook
the fact that they could have sex with
somebody because women would call up and
say oh i've dated rappers and updated um
uh
footballers no you've had sex with them
i did there's a difference men put women
into categories i can have sex with you
doesn't mean that i'm going to make you
my wife it doesn't mean that i'm going
to make you my girlfriend and women have
mistook the fact that they can have sex
with a certain caliber of man for the
fact that they can get that man as a
wife yeah okay or a husband not gonna
work that's true yeah i've seen that you
know i'm saying it's not gonna work and
so that's what i'm saying like a lot of
the time i think kevin samuels knew that
and i think a lot of the time women
delude themselves
into thinking listen yeah i can get that
guy because before that guy found me
attractive and we had sex
yeah a guy can have sex with a hole in
the wall
like this is what women don't understand
a guy can have sex with holding and not
know who's on the other side yeah
do you have you not seen this
do you know blindfold
women tend to a lot of women of this
generation tend to think that just
because a guy has given them attention
that that means
they're going to be wifey material a guy
will see a woman on the school run with
her bonnet on in jogging bottoms and
holler at you
okay that doesn't mean that he wants to
be your husband he just means that he's
a guy and he wants to have sex
yeah do you know what i'm saying
and a lot of and i think a lot of a lot
of those women called up the show
yeah i can get a guy no you can't
he's not going to be a husband
he's going to be someone who you have
sex with but he's not going to be honest
you can see through that show right
which is why right he kind of looks like
oh he's just coming he's just yeah he's
just coming straight out there
i mean okay i can agree with some of
that but maybe just with the content
i've seen because some of them i'm
seeing these women they're coming on the
show with a genuine intent to get some
information now i question why they
would do that knowing the type of
content makes but whatever but they go
on the show like for example the another
one i saw on on twitter was this girl
came and said kevin i really need your
help you know i'm trying to get you know
any man at this point i want to settle
down but i'm having trouble and then
when he got to her weight he basically
called her a linebacker yes and so she
genuinely went on there and said you
know what i really want to get this
council and he still berated her now
granted was her comments about was his
comments about the wake could they have
been framed differently and still got
the point across yes but i think if
someone's coming they're genuinely
seeking counsel i feel like you don't
need to make the delivery that harsh you
can still give the message
but if she is
if she's being unrealistic if she
looks like a quote-unquote linebacker
right
and she's asking like i said for jay-z
right
because i think a lot of the time when
kevin would
go to that place it was because he heard
the delusion
he didn't start off with just like
he didn't start off like that he he
would listen to your he would ask you
certain questions he would ask your age
your weight you know what you think of
yourself blah blah blah and then like i
said before a lot of women will come out
with these stories and and kevin
saw pastor bs i just think he saw pastor
bs and he's like
shut up this is what it was do you know
what i mean like i said as a guy you we
as guys understand when i just said you
know a lot of women get attention from
us but doesn't mean we're going to marry
them
the guys instantly knew a lot of the
women don't know that about guys you
know what i mean and it was like a it
was like a shock to the system for them
to realize like that in the uk
um there's a woman called lonnie lonnie
good i don't know if you've heard of it
right so you saw so lonely good is um
you know she's had
sex with rappers or they dated rappers
right
and she's in her head
said because she's had sex with these
guys that means she can get that caliber
yeah no but we know
when you look at her
really but i'm just saying a lot i think
a lot of the reason why um
women hated kevin samuels
is because kevin samuels was the truth
pill
that's my own personal opinion is it
because they're deluded
i don't think anything any but not
anything i don't think
so anything he did warrants celebrating
his death
well i can agree with that
i can agree with that you have to be
deluded you have to you have to have a
level of
ignorance to think that so and someone
mentioned a pact mentality that's
patment that's like
we all collectively disliked him and now
that he's dead let's all create a
hashtag and let's all come together
because it's a fun it's it's it's on
trend yeah it's on training it's stupid
yeah sorry i want to address because i
genuinely believe and this is my opinion
that kevin samuels does the same thing
right
he changes up the delivery and he makes
it where he's giving the same advice
i genuinely do not believe that he gets
the reaction he gets in death i
generally don't believe that now the
question is would he have been able to
build a platform the way he did because
a lot of his platform grew because of
that shock value you know so would he
have been able to get to where he got to
before he died questionable i think he
would have you think so
if you
but he built a name for himself by
pandering to women
do you so i feel like if cameron kevin
samuels did what you said he equally
would have built no but he didn't even i
don't think kevin even had to pander i
think kevin could have delivered his
message the same message
and i think that he could have just you
know made it a little bit more palatable
where it's like you're able to absorb it
without looking at there's no disrespect
i feel like you either have to be
controversial or panda you can't you
can't be you can't just give honesty and
that's what i was saying i don't think
his platform grows
and women
would prefer a derrick jackson to speak
to them
even though derek jackson lived there
absolute lie yes he lived a lie yes
right he was married and he was cheating
right
kev kevin samuel said yeah you've got a
high class man you might just cheat oh
you can't say that derrick jackson just
showed you exactly what kevin sanders
was saying but you'd prefer uh derek
jackson like baby you're a queen
you're so good girl you know i mean and
women prefer that type of stuff and this
is what i'm saying the reason why one of
the reasons why in my personal opinion
why kevin sanders hate is because he
just spoke the truth raw because derek
jackson is not going to say that he's
going to be you're a queen you can do
whatever you want but yeah while behind
closed doors he's having sex with
whoever
yeah and so
uh kevin tang was just broke he just
ripped off the mask
um guys though uh
do you think kevin samuels
helped with men's self-esteem 100 yeah
100 because he's saying a lot of things
that that men feel so again if you want
to use that video as an analogy of the
girl saying no one's wearing a rolex
the men in that situation won't can't
necessarily say anything or articulate
anything articulate themselves to the
women and even if they did it's like or
whatever i'm not going to listen to you
don't have a rolex but a guy in a
position of power saying what i feel
like a lot of men want to say to these
women or
or putting them in their place would
definitely make a lot of men feel
empowered
easily
you know
um
yeah that's what i think sorry guys
before we get to you we're going to read
some super chats first yeah okay
um yeah
that's a good question though
um we're gonna get some super chats
first um
here we go
okay we've got sentience again
don't worry about body count so if she
is indiscriminately gives her body away
to pookie chad etc with possible mental
physical trauma what makes any man of
worth think that she will be moral she
will make moral or sound judgments
for me or our child pair bonding is also
gone um
who else uh one sec we have sentience
again the female who commented on how
she would advise no that's an old one
oh hang on one second
okay tim naruth if you've seen medea
movies by tyler perry you spoke about
certain things in the films that are
true with real experiences for black
people
okay
um
i can't i can't find any more on here
you know okay so we have
uh kyle one body count uh asterisk nod
nod that was a
typo um
in fact sorry let me let me start from
bottom and then go up make sense
um
semaine tegan uh black men always went
for black women stats show it y'all just
have a hide mind and can't see reality
be on twitter black men don't have
disinvestment slash swirl
is it swerry movements swirl swirling
yeah
swallow movements yes uh courtney harris
harsh delivery is no reason to dance on
anyone's grave
true i agree uh sentient don't worry
about body count so if she
indiscriminately gives her body away to
pokey chad with the possible uh have you
read that one yeah i read that one
uh
boy type every person
a woman sleeps with statistically
decreases the chance she will be happy
when she does get married body count
matters 100
stop the cap uh kyle one
hide not count turns women into demons
a chick with a freshman fit had 700 plus
bodies
i tattoo black wait eyes tattooed black
teeth filled
pointy and face tattoos
okay and then he makes the correction
saying body count as such okay i am jt
i am jay got sorry uh averaged at best
chicks called in and wanted to talk
about what she wanted and talk about
and not the topic for example um so yeah
ks or kevin samuels had all the rights
to be bothered by her
um and then you've read tim naruto yes
all right that's everything
all right yeah sorry going back to you
today um did did kevin samuels help men
with their self-esteem i think so but
before for one thing i just want to say
one thing anything done in excess is
always going to be detrimental just just
to put down
anything you can drink water too much
wood
okay cool um but the disclaimer just a
disclaimer
feeling the pressure from the internet
is
[Laughter]
no but in general no i completely agree
with him
like
if someone's a voice to you if someone's
uh if someone's saying exactly how you
feel throughout the internet like i said
before people were talking about me like
whenever people talk about something
that they can relate to it really allows
them to
accept it and deal with it knowing that
they're not alone
um
and when someone can actually articulate
themselves and then not only articulate
themselves but defend you inadvertently
through like through um a debate with
two people like deluded people that say
they want certain things from
men which i mean they don't necessarily
deserve um because they haven't worked
for it they haven't
put themselves in a position to get it
they haven't worked on themselves worked
on their mentality increase their iq eq
whatever the case may be i have
emotional intelligence some people don't
know what eq is
um but yeah no i genuinely feel like he
definitely has improved it for men
generally yeah 100 you know 100 percent
back to the you know
masculine feminine you know like
literally he just like said the truth is
the truth just say it
you know yeah and i feel like it really
is
you know not to you know not trying to
belong to anyone or any gender or
anything i really feel like it's very
important you know what he's doing as a
man literally like if you're the you
know the leader of your household or you
know you're there what do they call in
english you know alpha yeah the alpha or
something like that right you can't be
the one you know lying or you know not
being able to tell the truth no matter
how much they were hurt right you know
you need to be able to stand up with his
child or something wrong listen this is
wrong if your wife does something wrong
this is wrong you know obviously i might
feel that way because that's the way
that we kind of was raised up as well
you know obviously african that's the
way it is you know like in a house
there's a house you know the leader of
the house i know you see he generally
will not be liked by everybody because
he will say the truth will be like or
not if you do something wrong he'll say
it you know he's not gonna you know go
to you like oh man son you robbed this
store oh i'm you know you're telling the
truth like listen this is that if you
like it you like it you know and at the
end of the day we won't know that it's
beneficial until like we've grown up
yeah you know and then obviously if
you've got little kids watching this
like oh
okay i'm seeing this guy you know they
follow obviously i'm not saying be
disrespectful you know
you know like be rude to anybody but
what i'm saying is it's very very
important for the culture i think you
know especially for the young kids you
know young boys watching this listen
this is how a man's meant to be i
believe in masculine and feminine you
know of course not everybody but i
really believe in it and i really
believe that it's very important for
you know someone growing up and having
this masculinity you know listen you
need to stand where you stand
say the truth you know be the man of the
house does that make sense yeah that's
like machiavellianism like where
if you
being in the middle um would be a sign
of weakness
um you have to pick a side that that's
like it shows conviction ladies do you
think yeah just ask a woman do you think
that men of nowadays
need more self-esteem
in your experience with men do you think
they need more self-esteem yeah
okay can say no to that yeah i can't
really i i can't really speak to that
but you know for example the
conversation we're having i know that
especially like this whole birken bag
thing you know a lot of i'm sure that
that has an impact especially when a lot
of men place their value in their
ability to provide services
so when you're seeing that women are
saying oh you know i want this birken
bag that when that's part of the popular
culture now it's like okay so what is my
value as a man if i can't provide that
so then i can definitely understand that
there has to be then someone who then
provides the the morale and that you
know that support moral support so that
you feel as though you're valued as a
person i think that is necessary to
counteract you know what's
happening yeah i agree yeah i think
that's a valid but also just kind of
going back to emotional intelligence
um it's not there um
what's not there emotionally emotional
intelligence for humanity
women
right okay both yeah it can be in both
which would contribute to
the insecurity yeah um because if you if
you can't understand yourself how would
you be able to
be in a higher state right you know i
wouldn't even say sorry no go on i'll
i'll i wouldn't say so much i just think
you're ignorant that's that because you
you don't come from
i don't know what background you come
from or you know whether it's a
single-parent household or whatever it
is but you know what's realistic and
what's not realistic you know as a 20 to
25 to 30 or 35 year old a birkin is
unrealistic so i won't even say the
reason you'll you want that is
lack of emotion i just think you're
ignorant no but aside from a birkin bag
that's what i'm saying the cardi b's the
nicki minaj for me for me because
if you remove cardi b or the hot girls
um i don't know what they're saying
that's the one yeah and if you remove
them there's no one no one's going to
wake up and say i want to book it no
one's going to wake up and have so you
think this generation has been deluded
by the
social media culture yeah yeah social
media culture rap culture and men as
well as well men are deluded by what
rappers say what rappers do how to treat
so it goes both ways we look to we look
to these guys as our heroes and idols
you know i'm trying to say so but the
difference is
the way it affects it affects the
society differently where women would
see that and want that and the 23 year
old is going to go to a 25 year old
boyfriend one of birkin
it's just it's not possible and maybe a
man would look at a rapper and see how
he treats a woman and wants to treat
women the same way but i think a man
knows his name that's what i'm saying a
man knows
this rapper has a bentley or he has you
know all this jewelry and i don't have
that so there's no way i'm going to get
away with treating a woman no we know so
there is a limit whereas for women and
on top on top of that there's women
empowerment and all these things they're
just going to feel like well
beyonce says it so i feel like and she
has a huge following
of women listening to her yeah
so they might gravitate towards her
psychology using things that she's
saying
i i don't feel like there's anything
wrong with aspiring
to want a guy who earns this or whatever
it is but i feel like the difference is
when you're looking down
on people who don't have that
you know or just not being realistic
even if
it might take some time to get it
or you don't even have it for yourself
yes yeah you expect somebody else to
have it that's the one and ignoring the
opportunities that are provided to that
person to have whatever it is you expect
them to have it's just
because that sorry go on going to this
oh no i just feel like there needs to be
a middle ground in terms of emotions
because it's very
especially with women because you guys
are more emotional than us
um is that
misogynist
it's just the way it is and it's just
like i feel when whenever and it goes
for both at this point is if someone is
in that position so say friends are
overweight
um
they might go to different extremes they
might go to the beyonces and feel like
i'm a queen
or they might go oh lizzo
yeah or they might go
backwards and say and have like
put like um self-image problems yeah but
there's never like
a solution that's always just like
either i'm going to delude myself or i'm
going to wallow in my own sorrow right
so it's there needs to be
that where's the middleware so all of
this kind of goes back to where we
started is the guy wrong all right he's
not i feel like he's the one that's you
know kind of seedless and he's like
listen this is where you need to be you
know i mean like i feel like this is you
know he's the one that's kind of like
saying okay this is where you need to be
you wanna beyonce you're earning 20k a
year ain't gonna happen it could happen
but i feel like he's the one what you
just said oh we need to be stopped being
diluted you know deluded or whatever and
just bang you know reality and that's
what he's kind of doing no i don't think
they i don't think the people who are
overweight would say they are beyonce i
just feel like beyonce makes them feel
good
about themselves to the point where they
wouldn't make a change where to the
point where sometimes
like
that's not good though no it's not
that's exactly so that's like they'll
make it their personality like some
certain people make their
shortcomings a personality without
actually saying okay
why did you laugh like that why you
laughed like that
because that that is very true like it
becomes a personality trait like oh i
just filmed my test
never got exceptions to school
but i think back to your question about
men being
insecure can you repeat that like do you
think that men need more milk more
self-esteem
yeah
kevin did kevin samuels help with that
i think i think
men do need to readjust but i think
with the way that society has moved from
way back before
um and women are more dominant and men
are more submissive so you can't
identify like the role that maybe you
should go under or even see myself i am
more of like an alpha woman but i would
still like that like i'm very strong
like i'm an independent person but if i
were to be with a guy he would need to
he needs to be alpha just more alpha
than me
because i'm not the like say how
traditional alphas aren't reserved for
women but it's okay going
but the the point is interesting if if
men are meant to lead the relationship
like
not saying that's how it works in
today's society um but traditionally if
men are meant to lead the relationship
you should no matter how high i am how
strong i am you should be stronger than
me
so what then the question now becomes
why are you so quote unquote strong why
are you so alpha
if that's not
the way women should naturally be
well that's just my personality like
i i don't i don't have you had to become
alpha i think it's dumb no i've always
been like that okay see i feel like
people are mixing up the rules like you
know oh who's alpha who's you know
you know i'm not saying you know oh you
have to be but for example oh you know
the way i was brought up like is equal
but when it comes to payment you know
protection you know providing yeah
that's where the man should be alpha you
know and they're both you know like both
own businesses you know but even my dad
would never like you know go out and let
them you know like that's the yeah
yeah yeah that's what we were told like
listen it doesn't matter how much you
know she's making at the end of the day
you are responsible for that household
so that's where you know we were taught
so it was like that's the kind of
mentality we have obviously i didn't get
it i didn't start but now i'm starting
to get it you know like
listen you're the one providing
protecting and you know what's the other
one there's something else you know but
he's this is the things that he's there
teaching us and my mama both got
businesses you know but never have i you
know heard my mom you know my dad told
my mom oh i'm struggling can you pay for
the bills or you know you need to take
care of your kids or whatever whatever
it is he's like i'm doing it you know
like that's the man jobs you know like
so listen if
so
so if
the woman earns
say five times more than the man the man
should still pay well like i said that's
the way we were up in it that's what we
are taught this equal in the house
they're there to help each other grow
dead for each other but when it comes to
providing protecting
that's happening that's a man's job you
know
protecting i i agree with you but yeah
provide when you say providing you mean
financially provided bro
i don't think i don't think providing
is limited to like financial means
because granted if if the woman is
making
sure five times ten times more then sure
then she
can help out more but i i think
providing is is contextual um because
i'm not perceiving it as oh just oh i
got all the money
because it's a team a relationship is
multiple
one or or two or more people you know
bonding together so
no one's in a relationship by themselves
but do you feel like if you were making
more than your man
that you would feel like
with your alpha energy you feel like you
dominate him
no here's the thing i am like i am not a
small dainty woman
like i'm i'm very on my when you say
small and dainty what do you mean like
in size no not in size but even like ev
everything like obviously i'm not like
you're saying that you're not feminine
i am in some ways but i'm kind of more
masculine like i don't think i'm a boy
but i think you're perceiving it a
little differently i'm just asking a
question but
like do you do do you perceive yourself
as more
on the masculine side or the feminine
side
i feel
but how i how i'm saying is like i'm
very strong so i can be independent but
where i'm staying in a relationship i
don't want to be that person
so even though i'm a strong individual
so have you been that person
well in the relationship yeah have you
been that masculine person in the
relationship no because that's not my
that's not that's not for me but i i i'm
not i'm not willing like i'm not willing
to do that why if
no
like i don't mind i don't mind paying
for things
i don't mind paying for things because
sure i like i'm young even so
i have
talked to people that are my age but
even if someone's older that
age doesn't mean you'll have more it
doesn't inherently make you like richer
or whatever um but
for me i couldn't be i couldn't submit
to someone that is not dominating what
am i submitting to
but then shouldn't you be in your
shouldn't you be in your feminine
naturally though don't you think as a
woman don't you think women should be in
their feminine naturally and naturally
men should be in their masculine
i don't think so because we're not
always together
because when you say i couldn't domin i
couldn't and submit to someone who is
not dominating it's like a man saying
oh i wouldn't i'm not going to be
masculine
until the right woman comes along
you know i mean it doesn't it doesn't
really make no sense because it's like
if you're if if your masculine is in you
if you're feminine it's in you i think
you can't say i'm only though go on
sorry sorry sorry sorry i got you off
that's sorry go ahead no i'm saying um
because that's that's why i kind of
think like men and women's roles have
been kind of like switched up because
it's like
i was in a relationship my last nation
for like 10 years and i was a protector
and provider and
i don't the things that man was supposed
to do so i know that's just who i am
that's what's in me right but i'm not
going to say
i do that for the right woman it just
comes naturally do you know what i mean
and so i feel like a lot of women
nowadays are saying oh i'll i'll be that
feminine woman
but for the right man you're either that
or you're not because what's gonna
happen is is that the guy's going to
come along and he's going to have a
struggle with you to try and get you in
your feminine energy like ah is she
going to be feminine now you know i mean
it shouldn't be a struggle it should if
if i'm naturally a masculine you're
naturally infected you're naturally a
feminine then we just go together but i
don't want to be in my feminine energy
as a man and have a woman be like when's
this guy going to get masculine
like when is he going to get masculine
what's what's going to go on and a man
shouldn't get of a woman
that's smacking saying when this woman
when's this woman going to get in there
feminine and i just feel like a lot of
the time
in these days and times i feel like
people are like they're missing the
roles that they're supposed to be in and
i think when it comes to the female side
a lot of females say i hear a lot of
females say i hear a lot of women say
i will be
feminine for the right guy
that's not that's not my thing no i'm
not saying you said that but i'm just
saying i hear that like men hear that a
lot is that i'm going to be feminine for
that should be your natural state yeah
because before it's kind of you know
it's like what you said right now i feel
like in this day and age that's what
everybody's confused about
you know i'm like you know what yeah i'm
gonna play about but when i get a right
girl i'm gonna be loyal
yeah and then she's saying the same
thing she's like now you know what i'm
gonna have my fun hot girl somewhere but
then when the right girl comes you know
what i'm gonna settle down you know be
feminine but it looks like
because what you're doing now is you're
building
you're building uh muscle memory yes
like in your in your head and in your
body so you're gonna be like all right
i'll be i'll be a whole for free summers
but when i get the right guy i won't be
it's like you just built that muscle
memory up of being a whole for three
summers like what you think you're just
gonna turn into get it like that and
turn it off like that when you get with
someone doesn't make no sense yeah but i
think we also live in a more egalitarian
society where you know the traditional
roles um that men had and women had the
lines have kind of been blurred over
time because you have more women in
positions where they're working whether
the time when women didn't work they
were just in the domestic position so
because you have a more egalitarian
society and you have people like
doing different roles that they
traditionally weren't doing i think that
you know what we attribute to
masculinity and what we attribute to
femininity some of that is mixing
together and i think that's kind of why
you know you have a society where people
you can say a woman's not operating in
her feminine because maybe she's doing
things that are traditionally masculine
um
you know it really depends on the person
you know some people are going to want a
more traditional relationship and so
they will
be the more traditional role some people
there they just don't subscribe to that
and so they're going to be who they are
and they'll get a partner who is like
that as well i think that where the
confusion comes when you have someone
who's more traditional you have someone
who is not traditional and then you have
them trying to come together or rather
they're trying to make it work in a way
that clearly is not going to work
because you want a certain type of woman
or man and they're not going to be that
person because they have a different
ideology based on the society we live in
and i think that's where the conflict is
but then remember we now live in a
society where men can be women and women
can be men yeah yeah
apparently
i just think that the whole out like she
said i don't know what does egalitarian
mean like equal yeah equal okay so
i think that the fact that like like she
said is we're confusing and we're we're
labeling it without because it is a gray
area that because they work and they
make more and they're in the position to
have that opportunity and because you're
less than quote unquote then they're out
for now it doesn't work that way
because
my girlfriend she makes more than me
but at the end of the day it doesn't
make me any less masculine that's it the
like it took me a it took even took me a
while to understand that
i even made that mistake once i told her
i said you know you're you're really
strong you're a really strong woman
but she had a problem because she didn't
want to just be seen as a strong woman
she didn't want to just feel as if that
oh she can just take everything and then
like you don't have to do nothing like
you're straight she wants to be taken
care of she and the reason why she's
like woman who are like that would be
with someone like me is because they
understand that
okay
i give in the beginning of the
relationship i would say
she had bare minimums
but then i gave her something
that is more important than what she
thought she would
she she thought that she needed which is
love care
i do things for her
i
i um i'm patient
like i understand like emotions stuff
like that it's like understanding
someone
it's i ask a question would you ever be
understood or would you ever be
appreciated
that like it's and it's a thing where
she says she'd rather be appreciated out
but it's
as time goes on i'd rather be understood
it's better to be understood 100
it makes you feel a lot better yeah you
feel me but yeah um in in general but
what i'm saying is in terms of the whole
question where self-esteem and the whole
alpha
mentality like you said i agree with you
because if you're a male a masculine
you're a masculine person you will
naturally do that anyway because i think
because men are now taking like courses
do you know what i mean to try and be
more masculine or to try and you know
approach girls and this kind of stuff
and i i just kind of think it's
i think kevin samuels yeah
he tapped in
to
a feeling amongst a lot of men
that men have been like feeding for a
long time i feel like kevin samuels
tapped into the fact that
going a little bit deeper that the
the feminist type of left-leaning
society has kind of told men that your
masculinity is toxic now you can't
really be a man like be more feminine
which is why i personally believe that's
why we have the whole transgender
movement because men have been told that
they can't even be men no more says all
right cool i can't be a man i'll be a
woman then okay fine do you know what i
mean so i think that
men
have
men were feeling a certain way and kevin
samuels tapped in to it and said you
know what
you can be yourself now and men were
like yes this is what we've been looking
for that's what we've been waiting for
we've been waiting for someone to say
it's okay for us to be us however what i
do just my own personal i let you let go
afterwards i feel like a lot of the men
that he tapped into
were angry
they were angry at the fact that they've
been told that they can't be who they
are and they built that anger up and a
lot of the vitriol came out because when
you look at a lot of the comments when
it comes to women
yeah a lot of those guys are angry
those guys would be angry because again
going back to that video of the two
girls wanting men in rolex's
everyone's
if those things we so the men are trying
to get your attention
and you're saying you're not interested
because you're not wearing a rolex i
will never get a rolex in the in the in
those guys heads so now they feel less
than
and they will remain that way because
there's nobody coming to uplift them
they will remain field unless then
they're going to constantly watch videos
of rappers and watch women
gravitate towards those rappers and they
can never be them
do you go on trying to say so men will
be angry they will just be angry and
feel less than and feel like they can't
achieve and then whatever whatever roles
are available to them society will never
amount to any not anything but you know
what i mean across the board
no one's going to be a millionaire
because
based on the roles that
um are available to us so they're
definitely going to be angry and there's
no there's no
in comparison to women
there's no safe space for men and men's
emotions and
even for example plus-sized men there's
no there's i can't think of one
instagram page or website or
for plus-sized men plus-sized men
whereas for plus-sized women and there's
nothing i'm not saying it's bad that
it's there for women it's great that
it's there for women but just to give
you you know a contrast there's nothing
there for men nothing so
back to your question if men need more
um self-esteem 100
yeah because it just doesn't exist
there's no one there comforting you do
you feel like that's a that's a man
thing as well because we really do do
that like we i don't think like unless
unless we really came together like
women do because they're going yeah
women go in the toilet together
[Laughter]
like why are you two guys here like yeah
what's that all about but it's like with
men like it's it's more okay cool i have
a problem i'm gonna i'm gonna find a way
to deal with it at some point myself
yeah yeah i'm gonna deal with it at some
point
you know there's not gonna be like a
whole
but if there was they still wouldn't
join us so men were missing community
and i think men were missing community
and i think kevin samuels brought men
together 100
yeah you know i mean men i think men
were missing that communal aspect and
you know what it was i think
um because what i saw from like a lot of
women who would talk about men who
follow kevin samuels
they'll be like oh this guy's your god
this guy's your you know he's your
mentor
but it's like
men had been
men and sorry women have been used to
men
not speaking mm-hmm
kevin samuels came
and men were just
still still speaking yeah women weren't
used to that like where's where's this
talking man coming from like you guys
don't talk you just like kind of sit
down and not saying it
i think kevin samuels gave men a space
to talk yeah and express themselves but
like i so i take kind of issue with that
because i'm just trying to consider like
when in history have men not had the
ability to speak
for a long time
emotionally emotionally men's emotions
would
men's emotions are not taken seriously
but i think that's an issue that is a
byproduct of the patriarchy which is not
something that women created women
didn't create the space where men were
not allowed to express their no they
never men created that space for
themselves so if you're gonna have gripe
with anyone you should have gripe with
men because men are the ones that made
the situation where men are not able to
express themselves you don't think so i
don't think so okay
to a degree you're right but if you
picture just a generic household okay
and let's say the dad's at work i can
see your mother
telling of a son
if he's being too feminine i can see
that i'm not saying it happens
everywhere but i can see a mom saying
man up or mom expecting the the the the
male
to be a little more tougher tough skin
in comparison to the woman so yes men in
the patriarchy created that but women
also
propagated
and i agree with that 100 but i'm just
going back to the root cause because i
definitely agreed that women have bought
feminizing their sons but
yeah i do agree that women have bought
into some of the tenants of the
patriarchy and are propagating i would
say bought into okay but what you're
saying is that independent no ideology i
don't think they have that
ideology because of the patriarchy no i
absolutely disagree because
some of these things are socially
constructed where it's like you have a
main dominant theme in a society and
everyone most people absorb that and
they reflect on their daily lives so if
you have a system where the man has a
certain role a certain position and
there are certain tenants of that
position if a woman ascribes to that
social construct then she is going to
expect that a man whatever his age is
reflects those tenants so in my opinion
if a woman is saying man up to a boy
because he's acting a certain way well
she got that because the dominant social
theme is telling her that a man has to
be a certain way i don't think that's
independent though i think that's
socially constructed i draw that back to
the patriarchy because it wasn't women
who embedded that in the society it was
men who embedded that you guys chose the
role that you wanted to be in
because you had the discretion to do so
and these are one of the consequences
that you don't have the space to be
emotionally vulnerable because now a
byproduct of that system is that you're
not able to express yourself fully you
have to come in a certain way because
that's what the system is demanded of
you so i don't think that's to be blamed
on women in fact i see a lot of women
advocating for male vulnerability i see
more women advocating for male
vulnerability more than men advocate for
their own vulnerability i'll say that
before you come women don't want a
vulnerable man oh you think so that's a
hundred dollars they don't want a bundle
they say they do but they don't the
second man gets vulnerable she's like
i don't think he's a bit soft he's a bit
women get the ick with men being
vulnerable
and that's one of the things that and
that's one of the i think one of the
reasons why kevin samuels
and people of the red pill community etc
become so popular because men were
allowed to talk about their issues it's
not it's they're not just crying every
day but they're allowed to express
themselves and i think women are not
used to men expressing themselves
emotionally because men
because because women because men have
understood that if they express
themselves emotionally to women
women back off yeah women women don't
like men being emotional
they want you to be a man
yeah that's that's what they're
attracted to
you cry
any of us cry right now in front of
these women
we would come for you like the thing is
if you yeah but you're going to see us
as a b-i-t-c-a i don't think so no i
don't think so not at all like you're
speaking no trust me okay there's a
difference between behaving like women
like if you act like
you're very emotional where it's like
you can't you don't have control you're
crying all the time like you you very
much
appear to be like a woman okay then
maybe you're gonna be looked at a
certain way but there's nothing wrong
with expressing emotion in the instance
that you feel some type of way and i
think that you know to say that you know
if you were to cry now that we wouldn't
come for you we'd look we wouldn't look
down on you i don't think a woman's
gonna look down on a man for crying a
woman's vagina dries up when a man cries
whoa i don't think it does
i i just i just i disagree completely
because you're able to be vulnerable
like i think that's more manly if you're
if you're willing to be vulnerable
really so you wouldn't want you want a
vulnerable man no not in that sense
not in that sense like oh you're walking
around all the time but you don't have
to let [ __ ] build up all the time like
it's okay to
let it go like you don't have to hold on
to everything i prefer to cry in front
of my boys if you're if you're in a
woman like a relationship say your
parents you know speaking you reference
your parents saying that they have a
partnership because that's what a
relationship is so if if i'm meant to be
your partner you should be able to rely
on me it shouldn't be oh no i'm going to
hold everything no you should be able to
come talk to me just because you're
saying your feelings doesn't make you
less of a man i respect that more
because you're able to say yeah okay no
i'm not i'm sorry
i respect that more because you're able
to vocalize and and say this that in the
third because it may it may be something
that i'm doing that may be affecting you
it may be something that's going on that
is actually like bothering you aside
from our relationship so
you you get more when you vote when you
vote women are attracted to alpha energy
they're attracted to you you can still
be a manly man
you can still be an alpha while saying
how you feel
and crying
let me interject let me tell you let me
know
it's easy to say if my man cries it's
fine when he's already your man but if
if he wasn't already a man and let's say
you were you had the
chance to be in the space of let's say
20 men on a regular basis and let's say
90 of them were crying you're you you're
not attracted
but who's crying all the time
every day
what i'm saying
he's saying the guy being your man he's
already your man yeah you've already
picked him because you've seen all the
attributes
in an alpha that you like so if he cries
it's fine because i know those guys are
is it after yeah yeah but before the
decision process of him being your man
if he often cries he'll be ruled out you
ain't taking that soft ass man
you ain't taking him you know you ain't
taking it disappoint because i agree
you'd be looking at him with different
eyes i mean he hasn't he's going to be
your friend do you know what i'm trying
to say i feel like that's friends that's
a factual statement it's easy for me to
say for example it's easy it's easy for
you to say yeah if
if my boyfriend loses his job and
he doesn't work for a year or two i'm
going to stop a year or two no no but
for example
but you go oh sorry
um it's easy for it's easy
for any woman to say that however the
guy doesn't have a job and won't work
for the next one or two years yeah but
that's not what does that have to do
without being emotional like it has
anything to do with it get get a job
like
what what what what voicing your
emotions have to do with not having a
job they don't correlate in any way but
i'm saying it's easy to make a decision
based on somebody you already know like
and love to say if he cries too much
it's fine it doesn't matter but if you
don't if you haven't built that
connection with him and he displays
those things that are already
unattractive yeah you're not going to
consider him i think
but i i get what you're saying but i
don't agree because no one you don't
have to harp all day so you know
you can you can say state
oh this is what's bothering me it move
like we address the issue we work around
it and move on like no one oh oh i'm
like no yeah if it's that all the time
no i don't
and i don't care if it's like a guy i
don't want to be around anyone that's
[ __ ] crying all day like shut up like
like do something about it if you're not
doing something about it there's no
point of complaining about it all the
time but
it
i i get what you're saying but i think
if it's my man or not my man like if
you're saying this is how i feel and we
address it from then move from there
that's perfectly fine but who is
actually once you address something
who's actually gonna like harp and keep
like bringing it on and on
like no one's crying all day like i
don't know anyone that's crying all day
and again i don't know anyone because
i'm not being around someone that's
doing the same thing all day no yeah
yeah two things like i said anything in
excess is going to be wrong yes it's
going to be bad
anything in excess but say for instance
the only reason why i agree and disagree
with the first one in terms of just me
and a guy say for instance you had a
really traumatic experience sometimes
you meet someone you know they're not
your man or they're not your woman but
like you hit a topic where you feel
emotional
and that really it might be your parents
it could be anything
but if it's if it's something that's
really dear to you and that person
respects it it's like if you cry what's
wrong with that even if they're not your
man like say friends i told you
something that's really really deep down
i mean that and i
the fact that even you're in the
conversation for me to even be there
yeah for you for me to even have that
conversation for me to get emotional i
must there must be something about you
even before and that's why i brought up
vulnerability like vulnerability is a
good thing not saying you have to be
weak all the time
it you're you're meant to be working
together so oh i'm not i'm not an enemy
we're working together so it's not all
you want a weak man no i don't want a
weak man but i want someone that's able
to vocalize
whatever's going on there's a super chat
um actually right now said from c
iron addict says how much crying is too
much and how would we know oh yeah
that's easy um hang on one sec let's
read the super chats out sorry
that's the only one i've got on mine
okay so i'm gonna backtrack on a few
super chats yeah go first uh sentience a
female who commented on how she would
advise if it were her show she said we
read that read that one yeah that one
okay uh to the female in the middle with
a tie my god please learn english and
definitions you were talking about a
degree of agreeability in a person not
potential
uh cement hagan
kevin samuel spoke pure facts but my man
was also unnecessarily disrespectful the
sisters would have took in his message
more if he was a bit more respectful
uh
mike by logic felons have 30 percent
more kids than non-felons women
absolutely go for bad men
sentience for fifty dollars
um so many
oh my gosh
so many vaginas running around here even
in male form
words do not have power anymore um
can you repeat that one so so many
vaginas running around here even if in
male form
words do not have any power only what we
give them
the only reason someone is considered
disrespectful is it because the
recipient knows the message is partially
true
do not don't accept the message if
it's not true
dog mpa
black men have gone through stuff too
stop miss sorry
stop the misandry ladies uh your mama
black black men live by
black women
for a white girl or black men will leave
white black women for a white girl stop
it ladies you sound crazy
um
have i missed any have you missed any
um
chat let me know okay
bear with me
is that it um just one second gotta make
sure you've read one as well haven't you
i've read one yeah yeah i think i've got
a few more
bear with
okay and you can't see any
i can't see any on mine no i think
they've disappeared okay
okay uh abs em uh
kevin samuels was harder on the men in
terms of his advice he also made men
more resilient men
came away from his call with thicker
skin
sentience
to the female in the middle with the tie
i think you've done that one no
i think it's different uh
you want to talk medicine i'm happy to
i'm in medicine pair bonding is sever
uh severely hindered after five partners
if she can't bond to you what makes you
think she won't take your child and half
of your stuff
courtney harris um
women with a body count over five is
static statistically where they can no
longer bond or stay married that's why
modern women end up serial dating in
their forties
sentience uh if the woman earns five
times more than the man
bad faith argument how many women on
average would be in a long-term
relationship with a man who earns less
what
you did what you did there sir is
focusing on is on sorry what you did
there so was focusing on the exception
and is very feminine
um sentience again a man who is more
alpha than me
so
what you're saying is that the tall fit
successful handsome man protects slash
provides and handles you why shouldn't
he get a younger tighter more submissive
version of you
i think it's
[Music]
have you got any have you got any new
ones hang on let me check
you may have i said if i haven't tell
them
i don't
oh hang on yeah
um from ams
914
you want
hang on want to know what women like
who are the male heroes of romance
novels
wealthy masculine confident leaders
checkmate the market says it all
okay
abs-m gender roles have been blurred in
recent times but our biology hasn't we
are attracted to the same traits our
ancestors were disagreeableness was
never sexy in a woman an alphanus also
and alphas never preferred it
um sentience
women sorry woman in the middle with a
tie oh gosh she's really going for you
uh you are very feminine your girl is
the alpha she
goes out
and gets the money while you provide her
with the love understanding
um normally what would women provide
their men with a
perfect feminist product
okay
um i think that does it for this you
know all right i want to kind of i want
to talk about it though um
i'm sorry that's why that's true throw
me off so
like
men in general
in general as men
how do we feel
about
our woman
providing
more than we do
i couldn't care less bad
you feel bad providing not getting
providing yeah as in financially yeah so
like into the microphone yeah so he said
provided not getting if she's getting
no yeah so listen if she's getting more
that's good that's yeah that's good but
provided but she's getting more
therefore she can provide no no no but
his point is that she doesn't have to
what i'm saying she shouldn't have to
provide more that's why i asked you the
question earlier if your
wife is earning five times more than you
you are still the one covering all the
bills i would that's illogical five
times more than you
yeah that's it so you make a hundred
thousand she makes five hundred thousand
yeah but you're where you living that's
the question exactly no no but that's
that's what i'm saying so you would
still you think you
you would cover still cover all the
bills
cover all the expenses one thing like
that's illogical one thing you have to
know as a man is that your money
is for the household and her money is
for her
exactly
i'm saying no i'm just saying in general
listen
it just happens do you know what i mean
because
and i've been for it like
it just happens that way like your money
is the one that's supposed to cover the
household
and if she makes any money it's for her
so really and
it sounds ridiculous i know but the the
second you start saying baby you can
have some money
imagine
no do you know
for me if my if my partner's earning
five times more it's not a problem
because because
in being entrepreneur you're going to
find a way to invest so therefore you
are an equal
it's never going to be i'm just always
going to be stuck on 100k and she's just
always
i'd be
in terms of my
values yourself
it doesn't make sense like i'm just
going to sit comfortably forever
initially i got a problem with it
because i know with your money
i'm going to be like let's invest in
something that can make us whatever it
is even if ultimately you still have a
higher percentage it doesn't matter
because we're continuously growing
exactly if she doesn't have that mindset
whether she's uh i'm not marrying you
well sorry
no no
she makes fun we don't marry anyway
nowadays anyways
yeah you don't care yeah but at the same
time
even though you don't care you can't
tell her what to do with her money but
it seems like you do care because you
would want to have more than her like
but what you're
initially i would it wouldn't bother
when i said i don't cares and it
wouldn't bother me yeah i wouldn't feel
insecure or less of a
i guess depending on who the person is
but if if it's the person who'd make me
feel insecure i just wouldn't you
wouldn't be with them exactly i wouldn't
feel insecure because that's and like
what you said that's your money which is
fair enough but i guess in my lane i'm
i'm gonna try to even if it's investing
my money to get to where she it would
never just be she earns five times a
month that's it yeah yeah and i guess
and on i think ultimately what it
depends on is
what do i want to achieve so if my if my
cap
is
100k
one bentley and that's it
i don't care because i've reached my
pinnacle i've for me anyway i'm not
saying it's going to be 100k people
always want more no yeah true but that's
what i'm saying but but it's safer if
you got there yeah if i got there
i've achieved what i want to achieve
like just because you're doing more it's
like it's like um
i don't know it's like let's say i'm uh
i'm a west end or broadway actor and
that's my dream but she's a blockbuster
actor that's in your lane here is what
you what that comes with but in my lane
i'm more than happy with what i'm
earning so
but then i think but
it goes back again back to what you know
we're talking about the main guy right
he's like stay in your lane yeah if
you're making 10 pounds don't go for
someone that's making 100 because this
is the problem that brings like i said
for me it would feel bad like i'm in the
house and my wife's paying for the house
you feel bad because the society is
turning into no no
money is money is not natural this is
man-made so you can't you it's not it's
paypal what do you mean that's what i
believe
like i said all of us do that's the way
you was raised up no no i was the way i
would you know what i'm saying it's like
the way i was raised up is like listen
you know you guys are in it together you
know i'm saying even if she's an
entrepreneur yeah she can be alpha
whatever but when it comes to the
household that's my money that's a delay
it's not a delusion it's so good that
way you know it doesn't make sense
i like it maths doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't add up
the money should be joined i'm not
saying
hold on hold on let me let me finish i'm
not it's obviously it's it's selfish of
me to say i
i haven't worked hard to get what you
have so what you have is also mine that
is selfish but what i'm saying is when
you're talking about paying bills or
paying
covering
costs and whatnot if somebody is earning
five times more than what you earn you
were trying to prove something by you
covering it you would not you're not
comfortable you think you're trying to
prove something it doesn't make sense i
think yeah you know what it is
you know what it is but you're speaking
from male emotion right now it's living
that is this is that if you feel like
you can't afford it yeah don't go for it
your wife couldn't afford it
why are you relying on your wife
what that's not her job you're not
relying on your wife you're relying on
the income stream that affords you the
ability to just get it
but that's hers though
what i'm saying i understand i'm not
saying take your wife's money i'm not
saying
no no no no i'm saying i'd invest it
[Laughter]
wait wait a minute this is a good
conversation you said take your money
and invest it yes right i don't know
what it is naturally yeah if you are
doing you know providing doing all that
naturally even though they might not do
it straight away if a woman is seeing
that naturally over the time she will do
something for you she'll either buy your
business do something or invest for you
while you know it why are you gonna say
oh you know what baby listen you're
making more money than me we're gonna go
split split
nah because you're being sensible
no no no no that's not sensible to me
man that's not sensible
okay i'm removing i'm removing the
gender i'm just focusing on the
partnership
if you have two people in any kind of
partnership
what man and a wife no no no husband and
a wife that distinction makes it hard
for you to grasp
i'm saying remove the gender
right you have two people let's say for
the next five years who want to get
somewhere one person earns more the
other person ends let's say half
right you're saying the person who earns
half forget the gender right the person
who earns half feels so much uh places
such importance on them being the
provider
for for what to prove what but we can't
compare that though but because we're
talking a relationship a man and a
husband
a man and a husband
[Laughter]
i don't know what it is
a man and a wife man and a wife so it's
not the same as a partnership if me and
you are living in the same house
partnership that's what i'm saying it's
a partnership between male and female
and she just happens to be to have
fallen into an income stream that is
higher than yours so you're saying no no
i'm gonna pay all the bills i'm gonna
pay for all the restaurants doesn't make
sense doesn't like i said to what to
what else see obviously we all have
different beliefs you know and obviously
the way we're brought up the way like i
said in that my household that's normal
i'm not saying it's not normal but it is
illogical
can i say
he's coming from a point where he's
saying provide as in you're not doing
[ __ ]
at all like you're not doing anything
like she's doing everything for you
he i don't think you agree with that
right
i think so because even say like oh you
have we're going to invest your money
because then what are you doing because
if we're using my money what are you
doing
how do you feel no no i don't think it's
bad but i think in this in this in this
example we're saying we're gonna
obviously it's a partnership and you're
making you're meant to work together but
i think
where he's coming from is like the man
is meant to provide so if you're saying
like oh
okay sure it's cool for both of them to
invest and to bring revenue to the
relationship but
if you're relying on her and not that it
always has to be that way but if it's
like oh we're gonna use your money for
this then i think his point is what am i
doing mm-hmm
where where is my money coming in that
we're going to invest like babe what can
i do for you not
but
so if the is that is that right kind of
yeah if the rules were reversed and i'm
earning five times more than my partner
i'm investing in every possible business
she can because i would not feel
comfortable that i'm above my wife
financially i sh she needs to be
empowered but listen right women
you're earning five times more than your
man
your man comes to you you've got two
women here your man comes to you and
says all right babe like you know i know
you're earning five times more than me
let's invest in something but let's use
your money because you got more
yeah
we saying
i mean i'm gonna be honest like
first of all please be honest let's just
get to the this i hate to go okay
i don't think that people should date
each other on the base of you know
compatibly as it pertains to salary
however we have to consider the
lifestyle of a person who's making five
times more than a person another person
right you're living a completely
different lifestyle so therefore
the partner who is not able to you know
keep up with and especially if it's a
man you're not in a position where
you're now having an incompatibility of
lifestyle and i think that's the core
issue i have no issue being with a man
who makes less than me so long it's not
so significant that he's living a
completely different lifestyle than i'm
living because now we have a completely
different livelihood and you and i'm
someone i have more traditional violence
so i want a man who is in a position of
leadership and who provides and protect
so i'm going to want a man who's going
to cover at least the more um the bills
that are more expensive of course i will
bring in my money but at least cover the
bulk of the bills right so if that's the
case that i need someone who has the
ability to keep up financially that
doesn't mean he has to make more
significantly more it just means to be
in the realm but when you're talking
five times that's like such a huge gap i
don't think i would be in a position
with someone who's about twice as much
that's fine that's fine because we're
living the same lifestyle so you can if
you were to cover the bulk of the bills
and i was to cover some bills we would
still be able to have a license because
twice as much a man could be on 50k and
you could be on 100. yeah i don't think
you live in the same lifestyle
i think it's what you spend your money
on also um because the person that's
making 100k they could be oh i'm going
lv every weekend i'm going gucci other
person they're going maybe they're going
at primark and they're investing that
money the the smaller amount of money
that they do have so overall one may
make more but they're not
so are you okay with your man or are you
okay with you making more than your man
yes and i and i would never belittle him
or make him feel like he's not a man
because that so long as he's fulfilling
the requirements of being a leader being
a protector he's he provides that
masculine force then as far as i'm
concerned we're cool you know and salary
changes with life there may be a time
where i'm making more money then he may
make more money that changes these are
changeable conditions you know do you
think your attitude or your outlook like
that is in the majority or the minority
of women i i think it's in the um
minority and i think it
i think it goes also
this social media lifestyle how you know
everyone's like oh
you don't you you don't have this or you
can't buy me this you can't get that
[ __ ] for yourself so why are you looking
for the next person to do that you can't
do that for yourself no because women
have that option no but it doesn't
matter the thing you're delusional to
think if you can't buy yourself like
obviously it can women are on boats in
dubai and they ain't got a bloody job
because they look pretty right the ones
enabling it yes that's true it's true
but that's why she can talk like that
because men can have no job but they are
no vote in dubai but that's if you got
no job bro you got no job
women ain't got no jumping on a boat in
dubai yeah that's not the reality for a
bulk of people like obviously it does
happen but social media influencers are
not
they're not the majority yeah they're
not the majority because they're
influencing the other people
you're you're meant to be an influencer
because you can spread to the masses
therefore they're not the majority
they're not the majority that's the
problem and the thing is social media is
a huge problem but i think see that goes
to the exception because i'm not saying
that those things can't be done but it's
unrealistic to say oh you're not buying
me hermes i'm not buying myself hermes
so why am i looking oh
you can't
yeah
but the thing is like i said in this
generation women can demand certain
things and the thing is that's one of
the reason why i can't and that's why
they're asses
because you're not getting it yeah but
that's what i think is kevin samuels was
so important because he saw women
demanding certain things it was like
you're talking absolute nonsense right
now
okay you can't demand these things from
your average man and my whole thing is
average men and average women
were missing each other
right they were missing each other
not because of men
because of women because women being
hypergamous wanted to go up
and the average man is very okay with an
average woman he's cool with an average
woman where generally i think average
women
when they get an average man they tend
to think yeah i can do a little bit
better
but and go a little bit higher but those
guys in that bracket
are looking at you
in a certain way do you think i should
okay no you go ahead do you think women
date do you
do you think a majority or minority of
women date potential
i think a lot of a lot of women you have
to ask women women
i'm telling you that so it goes kind of
goes against
no i'll swim in that question
i think women are going for potential
it's like oh he he he he doesn't really
mean that or he he can be better than
this or like in the future the future is
not now so although these things can
happen that's why like these things
can't happen it's not the reality no
that's why women hated kevin samuels in
my personal point of view because he
said
forget your potential nonsense right
that's what i'm saying i'm gonna
manifest my man i can manifest in the
law of attraction and he's like ah we're
gonna statistics okay he's like we're
going on statistics this is what happens
statistically and i think because women
have that whole
potential which to men who are very
logical which kevin samuels was it seems
a little bit airy fairy do you know what
i mean away with the fairies type
thing um that is one of the reasons why
i think a lot of women didn't like him
is because he broke
that wall down he broke your dream he
broke women's dream he said listen stop
dreaming and start being realistic
because the majority of women in your
position whoever not yours and yeah but
in the position that the women are
calling that the majority women in your
position
that dream's gone
okay this is the reality for them and
women i think generally tend to live in
a little bit of a dream world and i
think kevin samuels broke that down and
i think women didn't like it
let me know abraham
yeah yeah
you two still guys
so who do you think is paying more
and who do you think should pay more i
know who you think should be who do you
think
who do you think is paying more between
asap and rihanna
but that's different though no brav
a woman is a billionaire a woman is a
billionaire and he's just a rapper
right so who do you think he's probably
got 50 million maybe maybe
but that's different situation no we're
talking it's not a billionaire like
she's got a manchester united why does
that make any difference what we're
talking about is a woman earning more
than her man and that's a perfect
example that is i mean we don't know
maybe there's no way maybe you can buy
[Music]
make her pay for everything but i'm
saying in that situation it doesn't make
any sense that in his mind i have to
cover all the bills all the mansions all
the uh
it doesn't make sense what are you
trying to prove she's a billionaire
you're is
i don't i need i need
do you think he's the [ __ ] in that
relationship
i'm talking about myself bro you know
what i'm saying what i'm talking about
so okay so if you were asap rocky you
would have the same mentality so
he's a woman we're not even talking five
times more she's a billionaire yeah
that's best password it wouldn't make
sense that you still have this desire
that you have to cover everything i'm
not saying i'm not saying everything
though you said everything you said
okay so you're saying you're saying as
long as i cover all the bills in this
yard man whenever we're out there she
can pay for hakkasan she can pay for
five star hotels i would but how does
that make any sense i feel like they do
so as long as as long as the internet is
paid the gas is paid as long as the
water
can cover that he doesn't cover that he
can cover that
you sit comfortably and go outside
if i was in this position i would do it
you know i'm saying i would do it i
don't know i'm not saying you should or
who shouldn't i'm just saying there is
there is a there is an income stream
here and there is an income stream here
yeah right what what makes sense how do
we how do we how do we live if you're
saying he should cover all the bills at
home and she should cover all the bills
when they're out i feel like that's even
worse
like i said it's not about you know
what's sense or what's not i feel like
what's right for you what feels right to
you yeah so i'm
i'm attacking you so you're not saying
as long as you i'm attacking you
[Laughter]
if you're just saying exactly you're not
doing anything but i'm saying the
distinction the distinction you're
making is as long as the household bills
are covered
she can cover everything else i didn't
even know that's what you were saying
initially that's why like i said let
as much as i can you know what i'm
saying of course there may be time like
i said once you start doing these things
naturally she's gonna come right
right that's what i'm saying
yeah i'd say to me to me i don't want to
i'm not like
i'll be i feel weird
so that's how i feel
i'm not saying give me half and let me
invest in it it doesn't it would be
listen here are business ideas let's
tackle them one by one even it's not
even so my pockets can get fat so
whatever we've got going on can increase
in whatever [ __ ]
both pockets not just for me
because whatever she invested she's got
a stake in it so she's equally making
like it just if it i'm it doesn't make
sense yeah like i said
it can go on back and forth yeah but
what i'm saying is i would not just feel
i'll feel i'll just lose my sense you
know my confidence was gold you feel
like i'm home
she'd spend everything but that's
because where do i have no way you
wouldn't you wouldn't but i would i know
you wouldn't actually no you wouldn't
though
that's me but you wouldn't let me tell
you why let me tell you so you are
telling him
the reason why you wouldn't yeah is the
fact that you have goals right i got
bigger you have aspirations right big
ones right you're trying to do property
trying to do something yeah yeah all
different kinds of you're on a podcast
right now right yeah yeah so if she made
more than you why would you stop doing
that
why would you feel left in your
achievements because someone's doing
something for you okay and she's she's
fortunate to have what she has
you just happen not to have it
achieved less so that means you're not
successful she just happens to have more
that just happened she just might have
okay we got two more questions because
you said this right
guys would you be okay with being a
house husband no no
no really no no no
i tell you
i tell you what i'm not letting you know
i think anybody who has any drugs
i i'm not like i that that's what i was
going through and then we'll get back
traditionally like i would i i would
want to be submissive in a relationship
yeah i want them you wouldn't want a
house oh sorry about that hell no
hell no
because is he okay with house husband so
let me just make it make it contextual
um i personally would not want a house
husband but i think that if a man was in
a position where he's like okay i'm
taking care of the kids we have a
dynamic where he's doing that that
aspect of things he's doing more of the
domestic labor and the woman is doing
you know the working and all that stuff
i don't think that's a problem it's just
an arrangement between the people
personally for me
i wouldn't want a house husband because
i i wouldn't want my men to be in that
position but i think that it's really
why
because i'm more traditional i that's
what i'm saying it really boils the
person's individual value system i'm
more traditional so therefore i'm going
to want a man who is fulfills more of
those traditional aspects and i will
fulfill more of my traditional aspects
that's just it but you can't really say
that this is the norm or should be the
same for everyone because everyone has a
different value system i feel like it
works for people it won't work for me
do you think that your mentality is in
the minority of the majority i think
majority i think most people are sure
women want to
not like a house husband i think so i
personally wouldn't be a house husband i
feel like if you have any drive or
ambition it you you wouldn't settle for
being a household i just want to take
care of the children
i would love to take care of this work
that's right i think it's fine if you're
supporting your husband i don't want to
work i just want to take care of
children you want to pursue something
but i don't think it should be
i got my period every month
[Laughter]
i don't think i think it's
very possible for an alpha to be a house
husband i do do you know what i'm trying
to say it is i am guaranteed it is i
think that's exceptional oh yeah explain
yourself 100
alpha isn't it it's it's just it's who
you are yeah even if you are let's say
you're on job seekers allowance and your
girlfriend's on 50k right how will you
carry yourself how are you you have to
be laying the most amazing pipes
you have got to be laying the most
amazing pipe bro
if you're an alpha you know it it
doesn't matter what your wife is earning
it doesn't even matter if you're if
you're a house husband it does not
matter because you have hot are you are
you are you telling women that or is
that what you believe no that's what i
believe i'm not i'm not because women
would just tell you yeah they don't want
no households no i agree women won't
want house husband but i'm saying there
is a possibility
that an alpha can be a house husband and
you you're going to come home with your
100k a year job and he's going to put
you in your place because he's an alpha
i'm i'm not i'm not sure how she might
get being put in her place by her by a
work husband as well impossible
there's a video i saw i don't know how
true it is but i'm just saying that
women got work husbands that's probably
right because
impossible there's a video i saw yeah
it's a guy in
it's a guy having sex with with a woman
they have a relationship they have a
sexual relationship you know none of the
context as in before i just know what i
saw
and this short guy
i think he's back from prison or
wherever the [ __ ] he's coming from right
he comes in he stands in the stool and
talks down to the guy who's [ __ ] his
girl and he's saying get the [ __ ] out
and he's saying oh but what about my
kids the guy's like get the [ __ ] out the
alpha's here and this is a short guy
scrolling up to a tall guy with presents
and he's not saying anything he's come
home yeah and some other guy is laying
pipe in his woman with his woman you're
no longer the alpha he and the guy
leaves the yard what what you if you if
you like bro
let me let me see he leaves he leaves
the house what's the conversation
between him and a woman when i say alpha
when i say alpha in this context i'm i'm
picturing an aggressive i'm just
picturing like like a guerrilla control
do you know what i'm trying to say
if whatever i don't know the arrangement
beforehand i don't know what was
happening how this guy happened to be
having sex with this i don't know women
don't cheat on outfits bro i'm i don't
know like i said i don't know women
don't cheat on elephants
i don't know what the context was i have
no idea right it could be a situation
where they broke up ally
nah that's the truth because you're
you're not me don't cheat on outfits of
course you're not taking them seriously
this is clearly not alpha i don't know
it could be a situation you don't have
to know no no but it could be a
situation where they're broken up and
the guy's like no that's my goal you
can't move on i'm back now
that it could be that i don't know if
it's a change well didn't you say that
the the guy was in prison so he was
mandated to be away from the woman in
which case then she decided to fill the
time with another person that could have
that does happen a lot
but then that's that's not the alpha
like how could it not be in jail he's
not the man of the house
exactly the house okay he'll be in the
house
he would not be in the position to be in
the house standing in a stool talking
down to a guy and making that guy leave
bro if you're alpha you're smart you
don't get yourself locked away so the
next man can be piping
you can be doing whatever you're smart
if you're an alpha you don't get that
and this is a lot of things that people
get misconstrued i think in these days
and times like what you think because
you're the most aggressive and you're
the most loudest that you're the alpha
that don't make no sense because you
could be the stupidest right and alphas
aren't stupid so if i'm going to put
myself in a position where i'm going to
be locked up in jail for like five years
and stuff you're a dumbass bro like
that's not alpha behavior alpha behavior
knows that you're strategic and you know
you know what
alpha even knows when to get into a
fight and when not to get into a fight
because he can actually see the whole
landscape you've got to be a chess
player if you're an alpha yeah i play
chess i play chess every day do you know
what i'm saying
people might think oh you know that
guy's a puss yeah yeah yeah
no it's not that yeah i've already seen
three moves ahead bro so i'm not going
to go into that because i already know
where it's going to end up and that's
what alphas do and that's what
people like i'm going off on a rant now
but that's what people like putin do
that's what people like trump done yeah
yeah yeah they were alphas because they
knew if i do that i can see around no
let me not do that because i can see
where's gonna end and and then in the
end it's going to end them in a worse
position where on the surface people say
you should done that that's because
you're not thinking like an alpha a lot
of alphas don't not people think alpha
in my personal opinion people think
alpha is energy and it is sometimes but
it's also a mentality yeah yes
elon musk people may think he's a nerd
that's man's got alpha mentality
he knows
take over everything at any give that's
an alpha mentality take over anything i
ever give in any given cost
people
mis and i think specifically within the
black community i think right
a lot of quote unquote alpha men ain't
really alpha i agree they display the
energy of an alpha but their mind is of
a child bro yes their mind is of a child
right so so they so they keep going on
like yeah
yeah
that's going to land you in jail when
you're in jail someone's telling you
when to go to toilet yeah that's what i
thought
that's the alphabet
alphas don't get told what to do alphas
do what they supposed to do so i think
people need to understand what the alpha
actually is i think that's just my own
personality i agree alphas know
themselves like people think that alphas
do everything and take control of
everything and technically alphas do
delegate delegates they delegate yeah
they say okay i mean i may not i may
come short here
they they can they have the ability to
say yeah you have you can do this
well that's in my opinion anyway i feel
like alpha's delegate and the thing is i
think a lot of
this is what i think happens with a lot
of what the kevin samuels type women
that phoned up right they were attracted
to that energy of an alpha the women
attracted
that energy of the alpha
come to realize he's a child really
because now he's in prison
now he's on the streets doing nonsense
he got shot he died blah blah blah he's
not smart
i take in my personal opinion i think
the the mentality
is better than the energy
because a man
who knows if a woman knows her man yeah
she and if she knows him she knows that
you know what i know exactly why my man
is doing x and not doing y
i know because he's already shown me he
showed me so hence asap rocky
sitting at home and rihanna being the
billionaires
what's the queen the queen what's her
name queen this is your example
nicki minaj yeah
yeah i look at you know her husband yeah
she says it like this guy obviously he
has less but he does everything yeah and
i'm saying he was she went prison he
went prison yeah and she you know
literally is still with him mm-hmm i
don't think that's the best example
because there's a whole lot of things
wrong with that he keeps giving examples
guys sorry before we go last question
yeah last question right
if people followed kevin samus's advice
do you think relationships
in the modern time would be better or
worse better
let's go around and see i think it would
be better better
because it wasn't ill-advised
yeah
they would be better ultimately because
it's teacher he was teaching
or telling people to be more realistic
and if you're
if you're chasing something that's
unrealistic even though even if you
achieve it it's not going to last or
something is going to happen
that would be more detrimental
to you moving on than if you did take
the advice
so i feel like ultimately it was better
definitely um i think personally that
they would remain unchanged because
kevin samuels wasn't really talking
about anything innovative i think that
his message was things that you know you
guys have described kind of like the
biological factors that attract women to
men and men to women he was basically
talking about those same things and then
essentially saying that okay based on
where you rank in this scale
knowing these biological factors and
these social factors this is what you're
able to get right so i don't think that
really changed anything he was more
bringing i would say awareness to this
this this reality if you will
i think that where he would have had an
impact as if he went to a deeper layer
more about a character assessment value
system personal ideology who are you as
a person and how is that conducive to
you getting the relationship that lasts
into the long term he didn't go there so
therefore i can't say that he changed
anything i think he more of spoke of
what was already known and what you guys
have mentioned is something that men
have been feeling um as it pertains to
their relationship with women and i
don't think that's he wasn't saying
anything innovative so therefore i can't
say that he changed anything positively
would he have changed if people took it
took the advice yeah if they took the
advice like i said i don't think that it
changes positively because i think that
okay even if they master these
superficial attributes like okay they go
and lose weight you know or do some of
these things okay but are you a better
person because if you're already coming
into a show and maybe you were
delusional right and you said okay well
i want this type of guy and i have you
know and he said okay well you need to
lose weight and then you go and lose
weight okay but you still have the
diluted mentality so then that mentality
still follows you into the relationship
and that may manifest in different ways
he wasn't addressing the character of
the person their ideology who they are
what do they believe and how they want
to relate with someone he wasn't
addressing that he was addressing more
of the superficial factors that would
attract them to another person so if
that's the case then the question is
even if they do take that advice is that
going to serve as a solid foundation for
sustainable relationship i don't i don't
think so
today okay
after hearing him and then her she was
speaking exactly what i was thinking
up until a certain point so
at certain like when i put both their
opinions together it kind of made me
think more about what i was wanting to
say which is that physical attributes
are important if you're not attracted to
your partner
at that point look it's done i know at
some point long term looks fade
but that attraction to someone
you have to be attracted to them i'm
sorry but then at the same time like you
said if they did take the advice
they would be they would still wouldn't
be better because as she said he didn't
go in depth because even like she said
if you go to the gym i don't think
they'd still have that deluded mindset
i think that going to the gym builds
a certain amount of
um
uh
what's what's that word discipline
middle ceremony discipline that allows
you to take appreciate hard work and
that allows you to appreciate certain
things and working hard and achieving
something i feel like that can change
someone um but yeah i feel i don't think
no i don't i don't think so i don't it's
not from kevin samuels anyway if it was
from someone else
okay
i think overall just bringing these
conversations to the table um
but i don't necessarily think it helped
but
allowing the space to be available like
even outside of this podcast um people
are able to say well like you know if
you take your emotions out of it and
think
what what is the actual message what was
meant to be delivered
yeah i agree with him and i think you
know what he's doing it will improve it
obviously
the disrespectful you know this i know
those things not really but what he's
doing is you know just pretty much
telling people what they already know
but
it's like they don't want to bring out
feel like a man a man that man's you
know when you tell a man like hush
you know you're dirty you know i mean
he'll be like oh man but he'll go get
clean you know what i'm saying so i feel
like what he's doing is that
he's gonna improve things you said you
know oh he's not going into deeper but
what is he he said what did he call
himself a date culture what was it uh
imaginable
it was a day but as a date what do you
do on a date it's like you know go try
each other out so the things that he's
doing
is all meant for the starting point so
you know that's his job that's that's
what he put himself as you know image
and the starting point and if you got
that right then the rest will just go
along because you now know okay this is
a reality no more delusions
boom this is what i'm going to do this
is what you know we can work on from
well that's how i see
the initial stage exactly so i thought
that's what he was focused on he was
focusing on the starting point you know
where you see each other you know get to
know each other and then off because if
once that's right you know you're not
lying to each other you know i know what
you know i know who you are what you
want you know what i want you know who i
am and you know what i'm capable of then
it makes sense you know we can build on
from there but if i you know we're
meeting you know that okay you're making
2k i'm making 100 you know uh bro you
know from here let's just you know let's
not go obviously not man yeah
yeah i don't know what you know
so i feel like what he's doing
yeah it would improve if people took the
advice because he's focused on the
starting don't stop if the start is not
right then nothing is that building a
building yeah if the ground is not right
the foundation
is
the foundation
so then you're alluding to the fact that
these superficial attributes like right
those stuff that you know attract one
another in the initial phase you're
saying that that's a foundation i don't
but yeah i think that's the foundation i
see you i'm not attracted to you
and then i'm just like oh you know what
i don't like you i'm not attracted to
you but you know what let's just let's
do it anyway
does that make sense i don't think sorry
hang on guys guys guys if we got any
super chats
we do have some super chats um so we got
i can see tim
uh
ruth
it says to the woman
to the woman on the right side of the
female with the tie working
working out helps mental stability
working out will help you
find the guy that you want that's the
only one i have here you know why are
they saying that to me
[Music]
that's the only one i can see no i i get
what i get what you saying you're smart
for that okay so we have uh super chat
from zentiance uh
so
he's gonna have to go crazy okay
simp on the left still making bad faith
arguments you are using an extreme
example about rihanna yet trying to
apply it
atypical results generally uh to the
feminist who asked if i'm okay i'm good
i'll happily debate you and win
courtney harris uh
men not crying isn't patriarchy it's
biology
soft men are in
sorry soft men are ineffective at taking
on
harshness of the world and women don't
select them sexually controlling
emotions is both a survival slash
reproductive strategy
not a patriarchy
i personally don't
sorry i personally don't want a house
husband
notice how feminists love to play the
loose with a other people's lights sorry
let me start again uh i personally don't
want to play house husband in quotation
marks uh notice how feminists love to
play loose with other people's lives
morals
but want a strict traditional dynamic at
home
if you're not leading by example sit
down and shut up
and that concludes the super chats i
thought it was more than that guys and
girls thank you very much for coming
um
uh before we go
first before we go everyone go and
follow my youtube right now
okay otherwise we've got it's it's in
the link in the subscription sarah
in the description even um link in
description sara agave you can go follow
my youtube right now before we go um
everyone just tell everyone where they
can find you at
uh you can find me on instagram uh
candyfloss chocolate muffin
instagram at steph ume
i'm good i don't i don't really use it
so you can't find me
um you can find me on youtube i just
made a new uh new channel it will be in
the description it's called life with
raw okay yeah you can pretty much find
me in all platforms you know abraham
underscore s dot i dot d i think we're
going to put all of those in the
description yeah yeah
no
no i'm getting it now all right fine um
listen
thank you all for tuning in
um
that is it guys thank you very much we
i'm gonna see you guys on thursday in
two days time i'm taking over pearl is
back the new black pearl and um i'll see
you guys on thursday bye bye
yay
because i didn't know the face